Oh, exzellent.
Aber gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert. Eben muss ich gerade nochmal ausmachen.
Ja, ich weiß, ich bin schon relativ früh für meine Verhältnisse.
Aber ich will auch mal was ausprobieren. Und zwar...
Aber vielleicht warte ich mal erst, bis ein paar Leute am Start sind.
Das da wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Warum ist denn das hier kaputt?
Schmerzen.
Pression accepted. Was will er?
Wollte ich jetzt eigentlich... Ich dachte eigentlich, dass es funktioniert.
Ach so, hier.
Ach so, den kann der. Den schmeißen wir weg.
Haben wir später.
Also, Chat. Ich... Wie gesagt, ich weiß, ich bin noch ein bisschen früh. Ich will auch mal was ausprobieren. Und zwar...
Wir haben hier gestern diese Library hier entdeckt.
Ich hab grad... Ja, ich hab auch grad was gegessen.
Wir haben hier gestern diese Library hier entdeckt. Und...
Ich hab hier diese Object Detection Geschichte gebaut. Also sprich, dass der erkennt...
Daten.
Hier, Riesdaten.
Dass der erkennt, wenn einer durchs Bild läuft. Und aktuell ist das so, dass der immer...
Das ist übrigens auch nicht das schönste Vue.js. Das ist eigentlich eher so Vanilla-Java-Skipp mit ein bisschen Vue.js.
Sondern ne, wenn hier einer durchs Bild läuft, dann malt er immer...
...den schwarzen...
...den schwarzen Rechteck drumherum.
Und ich hab gestern diese Library hier entdeckt. Und was die macht, ist... Die erkennt...
...die, äh, quasi häufig benutzte Farbe in diesem Bild.
Und kann auch so ne Colour Palette generieren. Und ich hab mir gedacht, wir könnten das jetzt Big Brain machen, sodass das immer gut sichtbar ist.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, wir könnten das jetzt Big Brain machen, sodass das immer gut sichtbar ist.
Anstatt dass wir immer nen schwarzes Rectangle malen, machen wir das so.
Wir lesen aus, was für ne Farbe in diesem Bild hauptsächlich benutzt wird.
Und dann invertieren wir die Farbe oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Und malen damit dann dieses Rectangle.
Dann ist das immer gut sichtbar.
Also sprich, bei nem dunklen Bild wird es dann... Wir können es ja sogar schwarz-weiß machen.
Bei nem dunklen Bild wird es dann ein weißer Kasten.
Und bei nem hellen Bild wird es ein schwarzer Kasten.
Oder was in der Mitte oder so. Mal gucken, ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Ich hab keinen Plan, ich hab's noch nicht verwendet.
So, das ist jetzt nicht so Big Brain wie am Backend weiterbasteln.
Sondern irgendwas, was ich jetzt mal gut hier nebenbei zum Mittagessen...
...damit ich nen Einschlaf machen kann, Chat.
Daily Streamer, ja ich hab Urlaub, ich hab Urlaub bis zum Januar. Cool.
Wir müssen übrigens gleich noch mal ne Runde Amazon gucken. Nicht jetzt, aber...
Wir müssen gleich noch mal ne Runde Amazon gucken. Amazon.
Am-son. Mal gucken. Aber nicht jetzt.
Deswegen hab ich auch die passende Einschlaf-Entspannungs-Nintendo-Musik am Start.
Was hast du heute, ASP.io? Ich mach ein bisschen am Frontend zum Ausprobieren.
Vielleicht machen wir noch backendmäßig gleich ein paar Sachen.
Aber ich will jetzt erstmal ausprobieren, dass der bei dunklen Bildern den Rahmen und die Schrift...
...oder vielleicht, die Schrift vielleicht nicht, den Rahmen in der hellen Farbe malen...
...und bei hellen Bildern den Rahmen in der dunklen Farbe. Weil so erkennt man das nicht richtig.
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren. So, wie gesagt, da hab ich die Library hier gefunden.
Man sieht hier, die funktioniert prinzipiell auch ziemlich gut.
Also hier hat der irgendwie so einen komischen Teller mit so ekligem Gemüse drauf und Tofu-Sticks oder was das ist.
Und da sagt er, okay, die am meisten verwendete Farbe in diesem Bild ist hier dieses komische Blau.
Dann haben wir hier irgendwie was sowas. Hier dürfte die meistverwendete Farbe irgendein Grünton sein.
Alles grün, genau. So, und hier ist es wahrscheinlich was rötliches.
Genau, so. Und die Farbe lesen wir von dem Bild aus, von dem aktuellen Frame, das von der Kamera.
Und dann invertieren wir die Farbe und malen damit den Rahmen. Irgendwie sowas.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken, wie diese Library funktioniert.
Examples, nee, ich brauch Code. Code Examples, Codera Examples.
Äh, also, getting started.
Okay, das funktioniert für Node und in Browser. Das ist das Wichtige.
Also ich hab's auf den Browser abgezielt, weil der Witz ist ja, ich könnte das sicherlich auch im Backend machen.
Aber warum soll ich das im Backend machen, wenn ich's einfach, wenn ich die Arbeit doch einfach in Browser auslagern kann und mein Backend nicht belasten muss damit.
Ist ja eigentlich total beknacktbar. 16.000.
Leute am Start. Exzellent. Ähm, warum soll ich dann im Backend machen, wenn ich das, wenn sowas einfach im Browser funktioniert und keine Rechenleistung verursacht.
Zumal ich die Sache ja später auf den Raspberry Pi laufen lassen werde und da ist natürlich jede Leistung, die ich gespart hab und im Frontend machen kann, wunderbar.
Also Installing und Import, nee, das brauchen wir nicht. Was für ein Modul brauchen wir denn?
Aber besser gesagt, was für eine Datei brauchen wir denn? Welchen Modulformat?
CommonJS ist Node, das brauchen wir nicht. ES6-Modul.
Colorshief MJS. Okay. Ganz ehrlich Leute, ich blick bei Frontend-Formaten mittlerweile absolut nicht mehr durch.
Früher war das meistens relativ easy. Mit NPM hast du ja immer die Node-Version installiert.
Und dann hatten sie irgendeine Min-Version, die hast du im Browser verwendet. Easy. Mittlerweile haben wir fünf verschiedene Modulformate oder sowas.
Es gibt irgendwie CommonJS, RequiredJS, ES6-Modules, ich blick da nicht mehr durch. Aber Frontend-Up-To-Date zu bleiben ist eh so eine Sache für sich.
Also ich glaube, was brauchen wir denn? UMD-Module.
Das da brauche ich. ES6-Module for all modern browsers. Ich glaube, wir brauchen das UMD. For Simple Script Tag Loading.
Das, das brauchen wir. Das brauchen wir. Also Colorshief.umd.
Alles klar.
Meinst du das erste? Nee, das erste ist ein reines Node-Module. Das brauchen wir nicht.
Ach guck mal, da gibt es auch ein paar ES-Varianten davon.
Ach guck mal, und es gibt auch eins für.NET. Gut, so schön das ist, wir machen das nicht im Backend.
Wir machen das schön im Browser. Wir machen das nicht im Backend.
So schön das ist, wir machen das nicht im Backend. Wir machen das schön im Browser.
Aufm Klein, dafür ursacht das keine Rechenleistung.
Scheint ja auch ein Library zu sein, die ganz gut sein muss. Du kriegst nicht umsonst 9,2k, 9200 Sterne.
So, Dist. Nee, wo ist das drinnen? Source.
Was ist das denn jetzt? Dist. Umd. GS. Das brauchen wir.
Dann laden wir das mal kurz runter. www. Mit WebAssembly selber machen.
Mittlerweile ist, wisst ihr was das lustig ist, was WebAssembly angeht?
Mittlerweile ist das wirklich schon extrem mit Wahnsinn.
Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, da haben die FFmpeg, da haben die FFmpeg, was mach ich denn, FFmpeg.
Da haben die FFmpeg, das hier hab ich letztens geguckt, genau.
Die haben FFmpeg cross-compiled quasi irgendwie zu WebAssembly und haben da eine App gemacht, die im Browser aus einem Video-File mit FFmpeg ein GIF erstellt.
Und man sieht hier auch den Output von FFmpeg im Browser.
Also das ist mal wirklich Next Level Shit hier.
Hat, oder? Dass das mittlerweile läuft.
Nice, was geht hier.
Ich bastel ein bisschen JavaScript-Zeug jetzt gleich.
Aber das ist Poggers, dass du mittlerweile FFmpeg im Browser laufen lassen kannst.
Das werd ich bestimmt bei Gelegenheit auch mal verwenden.
Ich mein der Download ist immer relativ klar.
Warst lang nicht da.
Der schöner, ja stimmt, wo du sagst, letzten Streams warst nicht da.
Aber das hier Baro macht ja die ganze Modding-Geschichte.
Der Cute-Mod ist ja immer aktiv.
So, also Scheißzeichen mal her.
Wie binden wir den ganzen Cremple jetzt mal ein?
Ich verschieb das mal kurz hier auf einen anderen Desktop.
Ich tausch mal kurz den Desktop 3.
3 ist das, wo wir jetzt was machen.
Das Resize ist übrigens broken.
Ihr seht, das ist total kaputt.
Und sobald er jetzt wieder ne Motion-Erkennung hat,
mal das mit hoher Auflösung, das ist noch ein bisschen kaputt.
Pass mal auf hier, guck, Motion-Erkennung.
Zack, und jetzt hat das eine gute Auflösung wieder.
Und jetzt ist es viel zu klein, wenn ich Resize.
Sobald das neu malt, zack.
Ja, das ist noch ein bisschen kaputt.
Man kann doch irgendwie drauflisten, if Resize, dann müssen wir mal gucken.
So, also jetzt binden wir den Kram erstmal.
Nee, erstmal müssen wir den Kram auflösen.
Umt. Nein, umt.
Also typisch JavaScript,
wie das halbe Internet mit in der Datei enthalten, wahrscheinlich.
So, das können wir mal auskommentieren,
das brauchen wir jetzt grad net, oder rausschmeißen.
Die Material Design Icons, die wir jetzt hier haben,
die wir jetzt hier haben, die wir jetzt hier haben,
die wir dann rausschmeißen. Die Material Design Icons brauchen wir jetzt auch net.
Lassen wir mer mal drin. Schad nix.
Scheiß Truman, ich hab da nicht ein Icon drin, warum soll ich das drin lassen?
So, Script, Source. Und jetzt der da.
So, und dann müssen wir mal gucken wie wir den Kram damit benutzen, also.
Um
OK, so.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir den Kram verwenden.
Ja, aber ich will es nicht vom CDN holen, weil das ja im Zweifelsfall auch gehen soll, wenn das Internet nicht da ist.
Ich werde das aber nicht so machen, sondern ich will die Dinger gar nicht ins Repo einchecken.
Zumindest nicht so unmanaged. Wie gesagt, das ist ja eh aktuell so eine, wie heißt das bei Vue.js, so eine jQuery Vue.js Ersatz.
Also sprich, man kann das ja auch inline verwenden im HTML.
Ich generiere mir da noch eine ganz normale Vue.js Content App mit einem Node Modules Ordner.
Und da kann ich dann einfach sagen, hier nicht mit einchecken. Bam, dann ist Ruhe.
Du hast jetzt aber nicht die RAW-File geladen, oder? Oh, habe ich mich vertippt?
Ach nee, siehst du mal, ich habe mich vertippt.
Siehst du, verkehrt. Verkehrt.
Siehst du, der Chat passt auf. Der Chat ist big brain.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt da? Das Brauma.
Der Regel will man eigentlich immer das runterladen, das könnten die auf GitHub auch einfach so weiterladen.
Übrigens habt ihr das auch mit Docker Hub mitgekriegt?
Docker Hub hat jetzt neue Limits und das ist richtig fail.
Und die werden geflamed auf Reddit, das ist nicht mehr normal.
Also bisher war es so, du konntest Docker Images veröffentlichen, wann du wolltest, für immer.
Und du konntest auch so viele Docker Images runterladen, wie du wolltest.
So und jetzt haben sie es so gemacht, dass man 100, aktuell sind es zwei, später sind es 100,
dass man nur noch 100 Pulls am Tag machen kann.
Wer braucht mehr als 200 Pulls pro 6 Stunden?
Das ist die Frage, was ein Pull ist.
In etwas älteren Docker Versionen, zum Beispiel in der Docker Version, die in Ubuntu drin ist,
ist ein Pull nicht etwa das komplette Image laden, sondern ein Teil Pull Request.
Und da kann es durchaus sein, wenn ich mal einen Container runterlade, dass das unter der Haube 24 Pulls macht.
Und dazu kommt noch was, wenn man im Hintergrund was laufen hat,
wenn man beispielsweise einen Docker Compose Setup hat
und hat da im Hintergrund einen Check laufen, der nachschaut, ob es Container Updates gibt,
dann ist das Nachschauen, ob es Updates für Container gibt, auch ein Pull.
Ich bin nur drauf gekommen, warum das das Limit überhaupt gibt, weil ich letztens selbst in das Limit gelaufen bin.
Ich habe letztens versucht, einen Home Assistant Addon zu installieren
und da hat er mir gesagt, zu viele... was war das irgendwie?
Limits, nee, zu viele Pulls, irgendwie.
Dann habe ich eine Fehlermeldung, was will der von mir?
Und dann bin ich dann draufgekommen, wie ich an das Limit gekommen bin.
Erstens, ich habe einen Addon, das guckt irgendwie einmal am Tag nach, was es für Sachen gibt.
Und ich habe in meinem Docker Compose Setup ein Container, den habe ich so eingestellt,
Dann hab ich so eingestellt, dass der alle 30 Sekunden guckt, ob es was Neues gibt.
Und das war ich halt zack am Limit abends.
Jetzt hab ich es runtergestellt auf 12 Stunden, das reicht ja.
Was wird ja auch das Zeug bereit zu stellen?
Ja, das stellt glaube ich keiner in Frage, aber das Problem ist, dass es halt gerade
was irgendwelche Build Workflows und sowas angeht, wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal initial
ziemlich viel kaputt machen wird.
Es ist ja auch schon ein harter Schritt von Unlimitiert auf 100 runter.
Man kann sich übrigens einen Account machen, dann hat man 200 am Tag, ich hab mir jetzt
auch einen Account gemacht.
Da haben wir jetzt einen Account gemacht für den Free Account, das sind dann 200 am Tag,
oder 200 per 6 Stunden, anstatt 100 per 6 Stunden, und danach wird es ein bisschen teuer,
man kann also 5 Euro im Monat bezahlen, also der Preis ist prinzipiell schon ganz ok.
Was aber viel problematischer ist, gar nicht so sehr das Limit, also das Limit ist auch
problematisch an vielen Stellen, aber was problematisch ist, dass die Container selbst
nur noch 6 Monate gespeichert werden.
Das mag für den Hersteller, dass Containers vielleicht gar nicht so relevant sein, aber
für die Leute, die das benutzen.
Da willst du dir dann irgendwann vielleicht dein Setup nochmal runterpullen mit Docker
Compose und stellst fest, irgendein Image, was halt, keine Ahnung, irgendwie man ja nicht
aktualisiert wurde, was du aber verwendest, ist weg, das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Die werden auch übelst krass geflamet gerade, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, warum
in diesem Ausmaß, ich meine sie haben es ja wenigstens ordentlich kommuniziert.
Was ich halt ein bisschen doof finde ist, dass Docker eh schon auf dem absteigenden Ast ist,
ja die Container verschwinden glaube ich nach 6 Monate, Docker, Limit, Image, mal gucken
wo es steht hier, genau, genau und zwar, starting, there is no return, ich weiß nicht wie was
ausspricht, weißt du was, es bedeutet halt, wie viel es auf Vorrat gibt, ah ok, dann ist
es doch nicht so wild, dann ist es doch nicht so wild, das geht um Container, die 6 Monate
nicht gepullt werden, naja dann ist ok, dachte die 6 Monate nicht aktualisiert werden, weil
wenn es 6 Monate nicht aktualisiert werden wäre ziemlich doof, 6 Monate nicht gepullt
werden, das macht vielleicht auch die ein oder anderen Probleme, aber nicht so krass
wie 6 Monate nicht aktualisiert werden, ich finde es halt hat, dass der Sprung von komplett
unlimited zu doch jetzt relativ restriktiv, vielleicht wenn du irgendwelche automatischen
Builds machst oder so, da muss man sich schon überlegen was man macht, klar man kann die
Sachen ja lokal cashen, zumindest muss man umdenken, man kann es jetzt nicht mehr einfach
noch wild drauf fahren, was aber geht ist, man kann vermutlich mal Docker Login machen
auf unterschiedlichen Docker Instanzen und dann verschiedene Accounts auf verschiedenen
Docker Instanzen verwenden, was kommt als nächstes nach Docker, na es gibt ja schon
ein paar die versuchen die Docker Tools abzulösen, also übrigens danke für 12 Monate, das ist
ja übrigens Hypersubscription schon, es gibt ein paar Sachen die das versuchen abzulösen,
also Red Hat forciert ja da ihren Potman Clampel, der nicht so, ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist
es auch nur mein Eindruck, der nicht so hundertprozentig Fahrt aufnimmt, wo der große Vorteil ist,
man kann es halt komplett ohne Route laufen lassen, was ja mit ein bisschen Tricks und
mittlerweile glaube ich sogar offiziell in Docker auch geht, warum ist Docker auf dem
absteigenden Ast, ja weil die so ziemlich alles verkauft haben, Docker ja gar nicht
mehr zu Docker so richtig gehört und weil es viele alternative Sachen gibt die sich
durchsetzen, ja die ganze Kompagnetes Geschichte ist mittlerweile Docker frei und gerade Kompagnetes
ist ja im Enterprise Unfall das Ding schlechthin, da kommt Red Hat mit Potman, da gibt es noch
zig andere Versuche wo mir jetzt aus dem Copnet all zu viel einfallen und mein Docker ist
immer noch so im Kopf verbunden mit den Leuten, dass Docker gleich Container ist, aber da
habe ich mich ja schon öfters darüber ausgelassen, das ist ja gar nicht so, also man bräuchte
heute schon keinen Docker mehr um Docker machen zu können, ja und deswegen sind die auch schon
ein bisschen auf absteigenden Ast, ich habe jetzt auf Reddit gelesen so nach dem Motto
die Limits sind quasi die letzten Sargnägel für Docker oder sowas, vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben, aber es wird sicherlich Probleme machen an den ein oder anderen Stellen, ja
und was nach Docker kommt, wie gesagt es gibt ja schon genug Alternativen die man verwenden
kann, je nachdem was man braucht, braucht man eher was was dir ein komplettes Betriebssystem
simuliert, dann kann man LXC nehmen oder LXD von den Ubuntu Leuten, wenn man was braucht
was ohne Route läuft kann man es mit Potman machen im Enterprise Orchestration Umfeld
ist es ja eh hauptsächlich Kubernetes, ja und was nach Docker kommt, wahrscheinlich
nichts, weil alles was Docker abdeckt mittlerweile von jeweils anderen Tools gemacht werden,
keine Ahnung, ich meine Docker wird nicht einfach weg gehen von heute auf morgen, gerade
der Docker Hub war halt bis jetzt noch das Ding schlechthin, jeder hat seine Images hauptsächlich
auf Docker Hub gehostet, sei denn er hat irgendwelche privaten Sachen am Start oder halt irgendwelche
Builds, die er ab und zu mal gepullt hat oder so, aber normalerweise hat eigentlich God
und die Welt auf Docker Hub gehostet, das wird jetzt nicht mehr in dem Umfang so sein
mit Pull-Limits und Vorrats-Limits, also ein bisschen sägen die sich so das letzte große
Standbein ab, was sie ja hatten und ja natürlich kostet das Geld das zu hosten, das ist halt
die Frage, ob es das wert ist, wenn es noch eines der letzten großen Dinger ist, die
von Docker noch bei Docker sind, weil Docker an sich ist ja quasi verkauft, deswegen wird
ja auch kein Docker Swarmer weiterentwickeln und allem Möglichen sein, ob das nicht dann
wirklich so mit der Anfang vom Ende ist, schwierig zu sagen, weil wir vielleicht in zwei, drei
Jahren wissen.
Die haben es ja Patrick, die haben es ja nirgends geschafft Geld zu verdienen, die haben ja
versucht Docker zu vermarkten, haben es irgendwie nicht gebacken bekommen, was ich irgendwie
schon ein bisschen fragwürdig finde bei einem Tool, gut natürlich ist es immer einfach
zu sagen, wenn man hier jetzt daheim vom Rechner sitzt und sagt, ne die haben es verkackt,
aber bei einem Tool, was so eine Verbreitung hat und so einen riesen Einschlag gemacht
hat, Impact wie Docker, dass man da nicht so busy Geld mit verdienen kann, kann ich irgendwie
nicht nachvollziehen.
So dann haben sie angefangen so eine eigene Orchestrator Geschichte mit Swarm zu entwickeln,
die auch kaum einer benutzen wollte, ich glaube, dass das ein typischer Fall ist von richtig
gute Technik Leute, aber keine guten Strongs Business Leute, das ist ja eine Kombination,
die gibt es ja nicht so oft, also sprich Strongs und Technik Leute in einem gibt es ja so gut
wie gar nicht, deswegen ist Google ja auch nur so groß, weil die Dings hatten, wie hieß
der Eric Schmidt, war das glaube ich bei Google, die hatten eine Suchmaschine, die hatten das
beste Suchmaschinenprodukt ever, hatten aber von Strongs und Business keinen Plan, aber
die haben es richtig gemacht, die haben sich einen geholt bei Google damals, als die neu
waren, der einen, der Plan hatte von Business und der hat ja im Endeffekt Google zu dem
gemacht, was Google heute ist und mittlerweile haben die sich natürlich bisschen Strongs
beigebracht und können das wieder, die Google Gründer, aber ohne den wäre Google auch nicht
das, was es heute ist.
Es ist äußerst selten, dass es gute Techniker und gute Business Strongs Leute in einem gibt,
das heißt das beste, was man eigentlich machen kann, ist sich irgendjemand holen, der das
andere kann oder man ist eh schon zu zweit oder zu dritt oder zu viert oder so, so jetzt
fahren wir mal weiter, also ich wollte mir hier dieses Zeug runterladen, ja und Elon
Musk ist sicherlich super Strongs Visionär Mensch, ob der jetzt der ultrakrasse Technik
Mann ist, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, was er bei Paypal gemacht hat, das ist aber selten,
was hat er hier für Schmerzen eigentlich, Kundenoutloadmap, was juckt es mich, ok, also
wo fangen wir jetzt an, man muss ja auch selbst gar nicht so sehr alles können, ja, es ist
ja auch wichtig, dass man sich gut reinversetzen kann in die Leute, die den Kram kaufen, das
konnte Steve Jobs zum Beispiel gut, weil es keiner im Chat geschrieben hat, der war ja,
wenn man das teilweise von manchen Apple Leuten liest, also Steve Jobs war ja intern bei Apple
jetzt nicht unbedingt so, also der wurde jetzt zwar überall gefeiert, aber so ultra beliebt
war der nicht, der hat halt die Leute immer zur Sau, öfters auch mal zur Sau gemacht,
wenn was rausgekommen ist, was ihm nicht gefallen hat, also wenn man sich da Sachen von Apple
Leuten durchliest, ist es nicht, dass die gesagt haben, oh jawoll, heute durfte ich
wieder mit Steve Jobs mieten, die hatten eigentlich eher Schiss, wenn sie mit Steve Jobs mieten
müssten, dass der so saum macht, weil sie irgendeinen Müll designt haben, aber dementsprechend
der konnte sich halt gut reinversetzen in das, was die Leute kaufen wollen, hat halt
eine gute Vision, was man machen sollte, ja und deswegen, man kann nicht alles in einem
Laden machen, so also, wir müssen uns jetzt mal ein Beispiel angucken, wie das funktioniert,
example, bestimmt ein example, ok, vielleicht ich das jetzt vielleicht noch mal, ich kann
nicht richtig schreiben, die haben bestimmt ein example oder sowas, hier examples, was
haben wir da drinnen, js, demo js, exzellent, John Yahya, was macht der denn hier, ok das
ist übersichtlich, ich glaube das kriege ich gebacken, ja Tribulon, das ist deswegen,
das ist, das ist, weil das von irgendwelchen human resources Leuten gemacht wird, die
eigentlich keinen Plan von dem einen noch von dem anderen haben, also die Personalabteilung
haben selten Ahnung davon, selten Ahnung davon, Personalabteilung mag eine Ahnung
von haben, was was kostet, aber weder davon noch davon, deswegen gibt es so viele Stellenausschreibungen,
die nicht wissen, was sie eigentlich suchen, wir haben uns schon so viele Stellenausschreibungen
im Stream angeguckt, wo die dann jemand haben wollten, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche DevOps
Leute, die Projektmanagement machen sollten, programmieren sollten, Endkundensupport machen
sollten, irgendwelche Release Deploy Geschichten machen sollten, Einsatz zur Reisebereitschaft,
Einsatz zur Wochenendarbeit, Experte in Frontend Backend Monitoring, die wollten alles, wo
man sich auch gedacht hat, Alter ist euch eigentlich klar, was ihr da für ein Scheiß reinschreibt,
und dann noch, und dann noch 25k im Jahr oder so, ja, ja, stimmt, ja, das ist halt so eine
typische Anzeige, die irgendein Personalmensch geschrieben hat, der, der bekommt, die bekommen
dann quasi Posts oder Anrufs von irgendeiner Abteilung, die Mitarbeiter suchen, und die
kriegen dann grob gesagt, was die wollen, und dann dichten sie sich in Personalerkrempel
noch dabei, da kommt dann, dann steht dann zum Beispiel auf einmal noch dabei, ITIL Zertifizierung
und ISO, wie heißt das, wie heißt das andere, es gibt ITIL, ISO 9001, SMART, und was es
da nicht alles gibt, und dann hast du dann irgendwie so eine Kombination aus Skills,
wo total unterschiedliche Sachen sind, da ist dann jemand drin, der eine genialen Technik
versuchen, geniale BWL Leute, und noch geniale Prozess-Stonks Menschen, und das ist was in
Kombination, das gibt es einfach nicht, das ist total konträr, weil der eine, der sich
richtig für Technik interessiert und gut ist, interessiert sich in der Regel nicht
für Prozess- und BWL Zeug, und der andere, der ist nicht in Technik gut, das passt überhaupt
nicht, ja genau, und dann bezahlen sie 30k im Jahr oder so was, das bin gerade öfters
am Stellen anschauen, das ist echt Katastrophe, Entry-Level-Stelle, Master plus mehrere Jahre
Berufserfahrung, das ist auch, das ist auch Fail, ich verstehe es, ich verstehe es ja
auch nicht, wenn du dann teilweise siehst, so nach dem Motto, wir suchen einen Go-Programmierer,
irgendwie mit, und dann so nach dem Motto, 10 Jahre Erfahrung, so lange gibt's, so lange
wird Go noch nicht mal verwendet, weil ich weiß gar nicht, wann Go lang rausgekommen
ist, 2010 oder so was, 2012, ja, ist halt so, letztendlich erkennt man aber auch schon
darin, wo man nicht hin will, aber jetzt wollen wir das Ganze mal ausbringen, also wo ist was
sagen die in dem Exempel, wie funktioniert das, schau colors for image, ja, das finde
ich übrigens auch bei uns bescheuert, bei den Stellenanzeigen, dass, ich finde das sollte
sich durchsetzen, dass man das Gehalt reinschreibt, also ich meine, dass man das nicht auf den
Cent reinschreibt, ist auch klar, ist auch ein bisschen Verhandlungsspielraum bei, aber
zumindest mal so, eine Hausnummer, einen Richtwert, so sollte man schreiben, weil so ist es aktuell,
so wenn ihr Stellenanzeigen durchliest, es schreibt jeder rein, jeder schreibt überdurchschnittliches
Gehalt, was soll das überhaupt, was soll uns das überhaupt sagen, überdurchschnittliches
Gehalt, an welchem Durchschnitt orientiert sich das, ist das das, ist das das, was der,
was der Chef der Meinung ist, was überdurchschnittlich ist, attraktive Vergütung, ja, aber das ist
auch toll, oder was auch geil ist, wenn dann irgendwie da steht, ihre Vorteile, oder gehst
dir die Vorteile durch und denkst dir so, na also wirklich Vorteil ist da nix, da steht
dann so was dabei wie flexible Arbeitszeiten und Freizeitangebote und Firmenfeiern und
sowas, das ist doch kein Vorteil für mich, gerade Firmenevents, Firmenevents sind doch
nur bei besten Willen kein Anreiz irgendwie zu sagen, oh ja, da will ich hin, unbedingt,
da bewerbe ich mich jetzt, die haben drei Firmenevents im Jahr, endlich, Firmenevents
ist eher sowas, sowas, wo gerade Leute in der Technik sagen, Alter, bleib mir weg, bis
fünf Monate, monkao, ja, aber ich danke schon für den Sub, bei uns war mal ein Projekt,
fertig, und der Projektleiter hat sich, hat uns, hat zwei Leute gefragt, mich und, also
noch einen, bei mir aus dem Team und mich, danach die Motto, Jungs, habt ihr nicht eine
Idee, was wir richtig Geiles machen können zum Projektabschluss, haben wir uns so angeguckt
und da hat die Motto, eigentlich besten gar nix, einfach uns in Ruhe lassen, ja, und der
wollte dann aber unbedingt was wissen, und hat dann so ein paar Beispiele gebracht, was
der sich überlegt hat, da hat er ernsthaft gesagt, das denke ich mir jetzt nicht aus,
er hat wirklich ernsthaft gesagt, und dann fahren wir alle in den Kletterpark, und da
haben wir so da gestanden, und haben uns überlegt, sollen wir ihm jetzt direkt sagen, Alter,
wir wollen nicht mit dir in den Kletterpark fahren, ja, und danach, danach haben wir dann
halt gemeint, ja, wir könnten ja, wir könnten ja irgendwann mal die ganzen Beteiligten hier
neben dran, dass die Firma die Leute zum Essen einlädt, das haben wir dann am Ende
auch gemacht, ja, wir sind dann einfach alle mal essen gegangen, das ist ja okay, aber
in den Kletterpark sehe ich so aus, als würde ich in den Kletterpark, und gerade noch mit
Leuten von der Firma, ne, ne, Kletterpark, okay, also wie lässt sich der Kram denn jetzt
vertreten, color thief get color, excellent, image, gut, das fängt ja schon mal an, fängt
ja schon mal an, was genau ist image, ich werde hier raw image starten, oder ist das,
was ist image, image, for image in, ah, aha, image Datei, ah, der macht, der macht image
Element, okay, der will, image ist, der meint wirklich das HTML, den HTML Image Tag, ich
habe aber gar kein HTML Image Tag, ich habe nur ein, ich habe nur ein Video, das kann
man aber bestimmt irgendwie davon abziehen, Sargent Cheese, boah, Alter, was ist denn
mit denen los, bei uns gibt es ein Firmenwochenende, Alter, ein Wochenende, die sollen die Leute
einfach mal in Ruhe lassen, man lebt nicht, um da irgendwie zu arbeiten, sondern man arbeitet
da, dass man genug Geld zum Leben hat, die sollen alle mal sich in ihrem Kopf bisschen,
bisschen normal werden, ich habe jetzt letztens auch wieder eine Einladung bekommen, für
die digitale Weihnachtsfeier bei uns auf der Arbeit, weil ihnen ist aufgefallen, na, mit
Corona wird das ja mit der Weihnachtsfeier nix, also machen wir jetzt eine digitale Weihnachtsfeier,
aber man sieht, dass das irgendwelche richtig krassen Puma Leute sind, die das machen, die
diese Veranstaltung machen, denn witzigerweise, also früher, früher war das immer so, früher
war das immer so, man hat wirklich noch einen Brief gekriegt, wo drin steht, sehr geehrter
Herr Max, Einladung zur Weihnachtsfeier, und dann stand immer in diesem Brief drinnen,
war so ein Formular, ich nehme teil und bringe irgendwie noch, keine Ahnung, meine Frau und
meine zwei Kinder mit oder so, das konnte man da eintragen, und dann hatten sie in der
Weihnachts, in dieser Einladung auf dem Papier, hatten sie immer noch in diesem Formular stehen
so nach dem Motto, ja ich nehme Teil und bringe die und die Leute mit, oder du konntest dann
unten so dich selbst ausgrenzen, ich nehme nicht Teil weil, so und diesen weil Teil haben
sie dann irgendwann mal gestrichen wahrscheinlich, weil der Betriebsrat gesagt hat, sei dir
noch ganz bei Sinn oder was, 10 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub Nico, exzellent und jetzt musstest
du nur noch anklicken in diesem Dokument, ich nehme nicht Teil, so und nachdem die Einladung
richtig Boomer Style ist, haben wir jetzt eine Einladung gekriegt zur Weihnachtsfeier
per Mail und man kann sich anmelden, aber und jetzt kommt der Witz, man soll sich auch
abmelden, was dir eigentlich total hängen geblieben ist, weil wenn du dich anmeldest
und die das online zählen können, es gibt absolut keinen Sinn sich abmelden zu müssen,
es ist einfach die Fault Teilnahme sind Null und die steigt dann einfach nach oben wenn
man sich anmeldet, ja Patrick genau das ist auch mein Gedanke, ich glaube das ist zum
größten Teil daran, um die Leute quasi dran zu erinnern, dass es ja eigentlich gar keine
Pflichtveranstaltung ist, die aber Pflicht ist, also man sollte sich irgendwie verbunden
fühlen, dass man dann nicht absagen möchte, aber gut ich habe dieses mal einfach, ich
bin ja im Urlaub, ich tue einfach, sonst habe ich die Mail nicht gesehen, wer die Mail bekommen
hat jetzt einfach Quatsch, die sind einfach nicht in der Lage das ordentlich zu machen,
ja aber gerade also ich meine zur echten Weihnachtsfeier, da kann man ja noch hingehen,
weil dann gibt es immer was zu essen, aber zur digitalen Weihnachtsfeier, warum soll
ich denn da hingehen, du hast letztes Jahr eine Tüte Licht, ein Teelicht, WTF, das ist
irgend so ein Stonks BWL Mensch, der sich das ausgedacht hat, das ist der Wahnsinn,
ich soll die Leute einfach in Ruhe lassen, ja wie gesagt wegen gratis Buffet könnte
man da noch hingehen, achja übrigens wisst ihr was die Auffrührer immer als Vorteil
verkauft haben, das ist auch witzig, Leute die neu angefangen haben bei uns auf der Arbeit,
also wie gesagt das sind ja schon mittlerweile bestimmt 300 400 Leute oder so, also die Weihnachtsfeier
ist wirklich groß und was die als Vorteil verkauft haben ist, dass du quasi in die,
nennen wir es mal so in die Familie aufgenommen wirst, indem du, jetzt haltet euch fest, indem
du mit allen anderen die in diesem Jahr neu angefangen haben auf die Bühne darfst, darfst
du darfst auf die Bühne und mit allen anderen die neu anfangen Weihnachtslieder zu singen,
kein Spaß, kein Spaß, also das ist natürlich ein super Anreiz auf die Weihnachtsfeier
zu gehen oder, Kündigung ist raus, unangenehm, aber richtig, ich hab's nie gemacht, ich gehe
aus Prinzip nicht zur Weihnachtsfeier, deswegen könnt ihr, deswegen könnt ihr nur drauf
hoffen, dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig anfangen, dann sieht man euch nicht so beim singen.
In welcher Branche ist das dann üblich?
Ich glaube in jeder Branche, wo sich die jeweilige Firma oder die Leute das Plan für zu wichtig
halten.
Ich glaub das kann man gar nicht allgemein auf irgendeine Branche festlegen, es gibt
welche die machen mehr Cringe und es gibt weniger die machen, es gibt welche die machen
weniger Cringe, kommt auf die Firma an, wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben, also ich hab
das eingebunden, jetzt sag ich Colour Thief, New Colour Thief, ok, machen wir mal, Global
Object, ja Kingwall wenn man sowas gerne macht dann ist es nicht verkehrt, wobei man
ja sagen muss das war echt schon, also Weihnachtsfeiern können auch echt zum Fremdschämen sein,
ist übrigens ein gutes Weihnacht, das ist ein gutes Video für ein Video, ja, also
Weihnachtsfeiern können auch peinlich sein, also als ich früher noch beim Provider gearbeitet
hab, also da wo ich jetzt nicht mehr bin, da gab es auch immer so Weihnachtsfeiern wo
die Leute sich einfach nur unsinnig besoffen haben und da hast du schon teilweise Dinger
mitgekriegt, ich sag never fuck the company, da hat sie Dinger gelaufen, er ist zum Beispiel
war, ich sag ja keine Namen, ich sag ja keine Namen, ja wie meine Erfahrungen da gelaufen
sind mit diesem Thema hab ich euch ja schon oft genug erzählt wie ich es da verkackt
hab, naja zumindest ich hab das bei einer Weihnachtsfeier das mitgekriegt, wie gesagt
das war mal ein Provider und das ist auch noch ein bisschen her, das war noch vor 2010,
das ist schon ne ganze Ecke, zumindest da waren natürlich viele Technikleute und ja
da waren halt alle samt welche dabei, die sozial jetzt nicht unbedingt die Kontaktfreudigsten
waren, ich ja auch, ich hab auch so Veranstaltungen auch keinen Bock und dementsprechend war es
halt auch für viele so, als glaub ich die Weihnachtsfeier wirklich eines der Gelegenheiten
im Jahr schlechthin war da irgendwie Leute kennenzulernen, so und da haben sich halt
zwei gefunden auf der Weihnachtsfeier und ähm, keine Ahnung wie alt die waren, ich
sag jetzt mal beide schon mindestens 25 und die sind dann halt zusammen heim, was auch
immer und irgendwann ist dann die Polizei angerückt, also nicht zu uns zur Weihnachtsfeier
sondern zu dem Heim, das kriegt man da alles mit, das will man eigentlich gar nicht mit
kriegen, die Polizei ist zu dem Heim, weil die Eltern sie als vermisst gemeldet haben,
weil sie nicht von der Weihnachtsfeier pünktlich heimgekommen ist, wie gesagt die waren alle
25 plus oder vielleicht schon 30 plus oder so, also da sind diese Dinger teilweise abgegabelt
oder so, also da gibt's bestimmt auch welche, die sich beim Chef eingeschlafen haben, aber
bei der letzten Weihnachtsfeier bei uns muss es so gewesen sein, dass einer zum Chef ist
und hat gemeint, hier alter was ihr wahrscheinlich auch noch auf dem Klo oder so und muss dann
so sinngemäß gesagt haben, alter was geht, eure Umstrukturierungsmaßnahmen in der IT,
das ist ja überhaupt nicht gut gelaufen, war die halt zusammen auf dem Klo und dann
ist der Oberchef zum IT-Chef und hat gesagt, sag mal was ist mit euren Umstrukturierungsmaßnahmen
los, der XY hat mir auf dem Klo erzählt, da läuft's nicht gut, der XY ist nicht mehr
da, aber auch verschissen ja, wobei es fragwürdig ist ganz ehrlich, also erstens ist fragwürdig
jemand rauszuschmeißen, deswegen je nachdem was da war, ich weiß es natürlich nicht genau,
aber auf der anderen Seite, vielleicht ist ja auch was dran und ich denke sowas muss
man eigentlich abkönnen, aber gut der ist nicht mehr da, es ist aber ehrlich gesagt
auch ziemlich blöd sowas auf der Weihnachtsfeier zu bringen, also New Color Thief, was kann
man damit jetzt machen, kein Kündigungsgrund, genau ich bin nämlich auch der Meinung, ob
Kündigungen die auf der Weihnachtsfeier ausgesprochen werden in der Art und Weise, ob die gültig
sind fraglich, allerdings man kann sich ja mit Sicherheit irgendwas einfallen lassen,
warum das, ich gehe mal auch nicht davon aus, dass sie ihn rausgeschmissen haben, bei
uns werden ja keine Leute rausgeschmissen, es werden ja eigentlich prinzipiell so gut
wie nur Aufhebungsverträge gemacht und wenn man ihm zu verstehen gegeben hat, dass man
ihn nicht mehr haben will und ordentlich auf, dann wird es wahrscheinlich, wie es so schön
heißt, in beidseitiger Einvernehmen passiert sein ja, so also, wie benutzt man den Kram
denn jetzt, wie benutzt man den Kram denn jetzt, ich habe jetzt hier dieses Color Thief Object,
funktioniert das hier unten drin jetzt überhaupt, ich muss jetzt mal kurz warten bis da einer
vorbeiläuft, aber da müssen wir nicht zugucken und dann sagt man was, aber wie kriege ich
ein Image davon, ah hier, okay das funktioniert, wie kriege ich ein Image von meinem Video,
da muss ich mal kurz gucken, wie man aus einem Video, wobei ich habe doch letztens was in
dem Projekt hier sogar gefunden, wir schreiben das einfach ab, Video, 16 Monate, boah, Massive,
Alter, Dankeschön für den Sub, ja Martin, 16 Monate, das ist ja schon Hyper Subscription,
Dankeschön, excellent, Kingwall1337, das ist eine gute Frage, nachdem ich nicht weiß,
wie und was der genau gesagt hat, keine Ahnung, ja, teils, teils, so Umstrukturierungen laufen
nie hundertprozentig, so wie man sich das vorgestellt hat, auch nie glatt, unterm Strich
würde ich sagen, waren die gar nicht schlecht, wir haben jetzt einen anderen Chef als früher,
was auf jeden Fall deutlich besser ist als davor, also insofern, ich finde das nicht
so schlecht, ja, das ist der, der durchs Bild läuft, ich habe mir einen, so einen, wie nennt
man das, Click Worker oder so, wie heißt das, wo man Chinesen und Inder-Captchas lösen
lassen kann, nicht Click Worker oder so ähnlich, naja, ich hab mir so nen, ich hab mir so nen,
so nen Click Worker Inder gekauft, der läuft ja immer alle 30 Sekunden durchs Bild, bei,
bei Fiverr, ey mein Chef wurde nicht gefeuert, der ist jetzt bloß kein, kein Teamleiter
mehr, sondern wurde auf, hat, stellt sich jetzt anderen Herausforderungen, was hat dein
Chef für ne Ausbildung, glaub da hat auch mal Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt,
das gleiche, was ich auch mal gelernt hab, ja müsste eigentlich, ich weiß es nicht,
ich bin eigentlich auch wurscht, so, also wir gehen das jetzt hier weiter, Get Image,
wie kriege ich denn jetzt von dem Videobild, den Bild, was ich da reinfüttern kann, ok
machen wir erstmal Async Extract Color oder sowas, so, und dann brauch ich irgendeinen,
genau hier, Suggestion Video Canvas Instead of Image Element, ach guck mal, deswegen sind
GitHub Issues lesen teilweise gar nicht verkehrt, die schreiben nämlich schon wie es funktioniert,
F-Element Video, dann aufs Canvas malen, ah so geht das, so geht das also, ok, warum treibst
du eigentlich diesen Aufwand, gibt es doch mittlerweile so viel fertig die Lösung, für
was, also mir ist nichts bekannt, was das so macht, wie ich das will und vor allem nicht
mit den Features, oder was meinste, so Extract Color, die ID von der Kamera brauchen wir
und die ID vom Video Element, übrigens ihr müsst mir nicht sagen, das ist absolut nicht
Vue.js Style, wie ich das mache, ich weiß, also erstens machst du verschiedene einzelne
Komponenten normalerweise und machst nicht mit irgendwelchen ID's rum, Personenerkennung
und Objekterkennung kann doch hinquischen, ja aber nicht so gut, nicht so gut, und vor
allem nicht in der Kombination, wie ich es haben will, dass es auch in Browser gestreamt
wird, die Kombination aus Low Latency Stream per WebRTC in Browser, ziemlich gute Objekterkennung,
lauffähig auf dem Raspberry Pi, ohne großartig halt Last zu verursachen, außer ich mach da
10 Kameras mit Objekte Detection rein, dann bracht es natürlich schon so einen Raspberry
Pi auch mal an die Grenze, die Möglichkeit die Sachen aufzunehmen und sonst was, das
in Kombination, es gibt nichts, es gibt nichts in dieser Richtung und der Gag ist ja auch,
ich decode das nicht, deswegen braucht, deswegen ist das ja auch so Performance, so performant,
dass ich das Video nicht decode, ich schieb einfach die einzelnen Frames von der Kamera
in den Browser, deswegen muss die Kamera auch nur einen Video Stream ausgeben, den
den Browser anzeigen lassen kann, du wirst nichts finden, was fertig ist und das so gut
kann und in der Feature Kombination, wie was ich hier gerade am bauen bin, sonst würde
ich das nämlich einfach nehmen, gut ich kenn, ich kenn das Produkt nicht und es kann durchaus
sein, dass gerade Bosch Security natürlich was am Start hat, was besser funktioniert
für einzelne Sachen, aber das läuft dann garantiert nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi, das
streamt garantiert nicht per WebMTC in Browser und das nimmt auch garantiert nicht die Sachen
so auf mit Timeshift Buffer, wie ich das will, das kann dann vielleicht genau eine Sache
und kostet wahrscheinlich 50.000 Euro oder so, ne ne also in dieser Feature Kombination
und so wie ich das gibt, gibt es nichts und außerdem selbst wenn es etwas gebe, wie gesagt
ich denke nicht, dass es da was gibt, aber selbst wenn es da was gebe, ist natürlich
immer noch interessanter selbst zu machen, weil man wissen will, wie es funktioniert.
So, ich bin jetzt ja nicht ganz sicher, ob das stimmt, was ich hier mach, aber ich pass
jetzt einfach mal diesen, Moment das hier sind Fehler, das ist nicht Video, das muss
Element sein, Element haben wir noch nicht, ok, gleich, so jetzt brauchen wir die ID vom
Video Player, moin Fips2, die ID vom Video Player brauchen wir, wo gibt es sie denn da,
ok wo ist es, ähm, warum habe ich das da oben drüber kopiert, fail, Ende mal, kurz verschieben
das ganze, kopieren wir hier unten hin, weil hier unten muss ich das ja auch gleich sehen,
so also Let Element, wir können es auch IL nennen, ist letztendlich egal, Overlay, nein
das heißt nicht Overlay, das heißt Player, das Video Element, Player underscore ID, ok
und dann machen wir das hier mal, rufen wir das mal auf, await, this, extract color und
dann die Kamera ID, oh, ah das ist nicht, ist nicht essend genug, gut, ähm, jetzt schauen
wir mal, ob das hier funst, was ich da treib, ob der mir das Video Element jetzt ausgibt,
du bist ja Konsole, die bangen, Beste, ich mach mal kurz das andere Video rein, ich mach
mal kurz das andere Video, ich mach mal kurz hier diesen Fitness Dude oder irgendwas, ne
wir hatten noch letztens, wir hatten noch letztens ein anderes Video, wir hatten noch
letztens, ähm, wir hatten noch letztens so nen, ups, genau wir hatten noch letztens dieses
Pokemon Video, das war top, das war top zum testen, Club 3, war das Club 3, ja, Stream,
dieses Pokemon Video ist top zum testen, ups, nicht Curl, Run, ja, weil da passiert
laufen was und da kann ich direkt gucken, ob's funktioniert, oh, oh, ich hab's kaputt gemacht,
ok, aber Object Detection funktioniert, es überfordert ihn ein bisschen alle Sachen
zu erkennen im Bild, aber er erkennt, dass das hier Person sind, ok, hast du mal Magic
oder ane, ja ich hab Yu-Gi-Oh gespielt früher ein bisschen, zu Zeiten, wo die ganzen Kack
Noobs die Serie im Fernsehen geschaut haben und die Kackkarten aus der Serie gespielt
haben, ey, die sind so, solche Nubbles, das ist mein eiskalter, ne, blau-weißer Drache
mit eiskaltem Blick, übelste Crapkarte, größte Kackkarte aller Zeiten, hat nie jemand gespielt
wirklich, aber ich krieg das kaum noch zusammen, wie groß waren in Yu-Gi-Oh Deck noch mal 40,
50 Karten, war es nicht unlimitiert bei dem Yu-Gi-Oh Deck, war nicht sogar unlimitiert
und man hat aber nur maximal glaub 50 genommen, weil sonst zu unwahrscheinlich war oder waren
es 40, ich krieg das gar nicht mehr richtig, die waren auch gut im Vergleich zum Schwarzen
Wagen, im Prinzip waren, bis auf so ein paar Sachen, ja gut, was die in der Serie gespielt
haben, war halt teilweise auch übelst OP und die waren auch gebannt, beispielsweise
diese, dieser Wiederbelebungsspell war, durftest du gar nicht spielen und ein paar Sachen,
das war übelst fail auf jeden Fall, die haben ja auch, die haben sich ja in der Serie vor
allem selbst nicht an die Regeln gehalten, genau so war es Solix, 40-60 und man hat meistens
um die 40 genommen, ja richtig. Ich hab zu dieser Zeit gespielt, wo es diese
Karte gab, die dafür gesorgt hat, dass der Gegner keine Karten ziehen darf, das war irgendeine
Lohne, ja, irgendwas mit J am Anfang war es Jatta? Jattagerazoo war das glaube ich, genau,
war das jetzt?
jaaa
genau
ja das
wenn diese Karten einem Gegner Kampfschaden zufügt, überspringt er seine nächste Torephase
was auf deutsch so viel heißt wie
wenn du den Gegner damit triffst darf er keine Karten mehr ziehen
das war, das war so unglaublich dämlich OP
dass es schon lustig war
weil der Gegner, wenn der, wenn der Gegner nichts machen konnte, konnte der
wahrscheinlich nächsten Turn auch nichts machen
also du hast den Gegner einmal angegriffen, damit Damage gemacht, hast in der Regel
instant gewonnen, das war richtig schwachsinnig
ich erinnere mich noch dunkel dran
aber Yu-Gi-Oh Karten sind nix wert ne
ich hab letztens mal auf Ebay geguckt
und Sachen die damals übelst begehrt waren
irgendwelche Rare, Jinso, sonst was Dinger kosten heute 250 auf Ebay oder so
also Magic Karten haben den Wert eindeutig besser gehalten als Yu-Gi-Oh Karten
wobei ich nie Magic gespielt hab, aber Magic Karten kannst du ja teilweise übelst teure
Dinger
heute noch
da ordern und trainen
aber Yu-Gi-Oh ist, ich glaube es ist einfach auch nicht mehr so angesagt
ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich hab irgendwann das Interesse verloren
und mittlerweile habe ich überhaupt kein Überblick mehr was da abgeht
es gibt ja mittlerweile 50 Milliarden
Addons mit
Dingern drauf, wurde der alte Blick slammerndrisch
Pokémon Karten mega eskalieren, ja da müsste man Fabian fragen, der hatte ja immer die
Kinders abgezogen früher, hab ich mir sagen lassen mit Pokémon Karten
da ist er ja, da ist er ja
der Frasier
aufs Kommando
ja
das ist ja geil
ich hab gerade nur festgestellt, dass Yu-Gi-Oh Karten überhaupt ihren Wert
nicht gut gehalten haben, wenn man auf Ebay guckt
kriegst du teilweise Dinge, übelst rare Sachen von früher, heute von 250
und
Magic hat auf jeden Fall den Wert viel besser gehalten
und da meinte der Chat, was halt voll abgeht, gerade sind Yu-Gi-Oh Karten
und da hab ich halt gesagt, müsste man den Fabian fragen, der hat früher die Kinders immer abgezogen
mit Yu-Gi-Oh gar nicht, mit Pokémon Karten
exzellent
du bekommst 25k easy
easy money easy life
du solltest da ein Youtube Video drüber machen und deine Rare Karten zeigen, das kommt bestimmt
übelst gut an
du brauchst irgendeinen richtig krassen Clickbait Titel
du glaubst nicht, was diese Yu-Gi-Oh Karten wert sind und unten drunter schreibst du dann
irgendwie zwei Millionen oder so
und machst um die eine Yu-Gi-Oh-Karte noch einen roten Kreis
nee, Drehkick, leider bekommt man für
Videoaufrufe nicht allzu viel
das Video von mir mit den meisten Aufrufen hat irgendwie 2,3 Millionen Aufrufe
und damit hab ich so gut wie nix verdient
Max und Friseur reveal aus der Pokémon Karte
aber Fabian, jetzt wohnen wir wieder zurück
unter den lebenden Bist auf YouTube
auf YouTube
dann müssen wir auch mal wieder an Weihnachten was aufnehmen, nicht jetzt gleich, mir fällt jetzt auch gar kein
richtiges Thema ein, so irgendwann zu 5.24 oder so
Lol, du hast ein Video gemacht, ja hast schon mehr gemacht als ich
mehr als ich auf jeden Fall
ich hab glaub ich seit acht Monaten kein Video mehr gemacht oder so
Bitte wieder eine besoffene Neujahrsansprache
nee, oder, keine Ahnung, mal gucken
Du hast fünf Jahre keins gemacht, ja gut, das verjährt ja irgendwann auch
das letzte halbe Jahr ist ja relevant immer
hab ich, sag ich jetzt einfach mal so
Du hast das Problem, dass die meisten deiner Zuschauer wahrscheinlich Adblocker haben
ja, wahrscheinlich schon
aber das Video war halt absolut nicht werbegeeignet, das was 2,3 Millionen hat
und ich weiß bis heute nicht warum dieses Video
Leute, für die die es nicht wissen, dass mein meistgesehenes Video ist
das hier
nee
ich lauf im Schnee durch meinen Garten
es passiert in diesem, es ist die Baustelle, das ist wo wir grad das Haus renoviert haben
ich lauf über die Baustelle im Schnee
guckt euch das mal an
2 Millionen 76.045
kannst du keinem erzählen, ja
der YouTube Algorithmus hat sich gedacht
das möchte die Welt sehen
da haben die Leute geschaut, wie ich im Schnee spiegel
hier, ich spiegel mich im Eis vom Fischteich
also warum
warum dieses Video so
warum der YouTube, das war auf der Startseite von YouTube, das war auf der Startseite
ein Video
wo ich verwackelt mit dem Handy durch den Garten laufe
war bei YouTube auf der Startseite
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
richtig hängen geblieben
es passiert auch absolut nichts in dem Video, außer dass ich durch meinen Garten laufe
das ist noch nicht mal ein Video mit irgendeinem Jumpscare drin oder sowas
es passiert einfach gar nichts
warum hat das Ding 1,3K Dislikes
naja, weil es die Leute empfohlen bekommen haben
und haben sich das Video angeguckt und haben sich gedacht, was ist das für ein Scheiß
da haben sie auch recht
ein Video was
ja, ne, das kann ich auf Twitch nicht zeigen
ich hab noch ein Video gemacht, wo ich die Bilder von meinem Opa unterm Dachboden
gezeigt hab
und da waren halt ein paar naggische Mädels auf den Bildern drauf, ich weiß nicht ob das
nicht Twitch-Toss ist
halt gemalt
na, auf YouTube ist es kein Problem, aber auf Twitch bin ich mir da nicht so sicher
auf Twitch ist im Zweifelsfall alles Monkartoss
wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben jetzt, genau, ich wollt gucken wie ich das Bild von da
zum Farben erkennen überreden kann
wann zeigt die Sylvaner ihre Tippen
ich weiß gar nicht ob die Sylvaner überhaupt noch in Deutschland ist
ich glaub die ist ausgewandert irgendwann mal
warum ist die Refresh Time so niedrig, was für eine Refresh Time
ok, was hab ich denn verkehrt gemacht
ja, ich mach's ja mit dem Archiv so
mein Archiv ist ja nicht auf Twitch, so, und dann fällt Twitch schon mal raus
ok, Player ID
was hat er für Schmerzen, Cannot Read of Undefined
was hab ich verkehrt gemacht
ah, es heißt doch nicht Element, sondern EL
geht's jetzt
ah, ne
was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen, Cannot Get Context
ah, das ist das davor, das muss man
machst gut Fabian, bis denn
musst du EL-Stells machen
Real Life Stells
Genshin Impact Dailies machen
ah, Kreiselgrind, exellent
so, ah, Moment, das hier muss auch noch weg
also den Gaul nicht erkennt
was hat er denn für Schmerzen, Video is not defined
warum nicht
ah, weil es nicht Video heißt, sondern EL
ok, ok, so, und jetzt müssen wir die Color extrahieren
Hallo, it's Epic
exquisite name
ja, auf Twitch geht es mit den Strikes gerade richtig ab, so wie auf YouTube von
vor ein paar Jahren
so, ich wollte es ja hier klauen, was der Typ da geschrieben hat, ok, Tour Image
das heißt im Endeffekt, jetzt hab ich
jetzt hab ich das Videobild
auf ein verstecktes Canvas gemalt und kann ich da jetzt einfach
einfach Erkennung drauf machen
was ist denn mit meinem Editor hier los
was ist, Get Color
kann man da jetzt einfach irgendwie das Canvas reinschieben oder so und dann geht's
wahrscheinlich nicht
oh MonkaS, natürlich geht das nicht
natürlich geht das nicht
is not defined, ah ja, ok, ok, ich weiß warum das nicht geht
oh Mist
was hat er denn
fail to execute Get Image Data
ok, der Scheiß funktioniert wirklich nur mit echten Images, wie es aussieht
wie kriegt man denn aus einem Canvas eine Image
ok, ah ja, Google
Canvas to Image
Javascript
to data URL, ok
wieso kein jQuery, weil jQuery irgendwie so 2005 ist
und wir sind ja modern
deswegen sagen wir auch nicht Ubuntu, sondern sagen
Ubuntu
und sagen Amazon anstatt Amazon und deswegen verwenden wir auch Vue.js anstatt
jQuery
weil wir richtig krasse Hacker Mans sind
und da wird mir der Chat recht geben, richtig krasse Hacker Mans verwenden
kein jQuery
was muss man jetzt hier machen, to data
URL
funktioniert das jetzt, ok, das geben wir jetzt mal aus, das heißt wenn ich sagen
to data URL, da kommt da irgendein so ein langer
langer Base64-encodeder
String dabei raus
was dem Bild entspricht, ok
müsstest du da nicht Svelte nehmen, doch
wollte ich auch schon mal ausprobieren
Svelte to execute, ah Moment
mal kurz wegmachen
Svelte wollte ich auch schon ganz lange mal ausprobieren, hab ich sogar in meinem To Do hier
irgendwo drinstehen, guck mal hier
nein, hab ich nicht drinstehen, dann schreibe ich es rein
das wollte ich schon ganz lange mal ausprobieren, ich finde Svelte ist eine
richtig gute Idee
aber Svelte ist richtig nice, ich hab schon viele Tutorials geguckt dazu
und das was ich gesehen hab, finde ich wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr nice
was halt
was man damit nicht machen kann, ist quasi so wie ich, jetzt mach alles hier inline
im Browser schreiben, also sprich
da brauchst du schon
dieses ganze Generator Zeug, weil das ja für dich das
zusammenbaut dann
ne, jQuery ist nicht mehr angesagt
Eternity Hype, jQuery ist schon seit
bestimmt 10 Jahren out
aufgeräumt der Desktop, doch klar
der ist aufgeräumt, guck mal
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Bild suche von der Katze, weiß ich genau das da unten
oder ein Bild von einer Katze ist da oben
easy, das ist das wichtigste was man wissen muss, man muss wissen
wo man das Bild von seinen zwei Katzen
auf dem Desktop hat
ansonsten der Rest ist egal
ja also wie gesagt, jQuery ist total out mittlerweile
also
es gibt eigentlich drei Sachen, die so richtig
weit verbreitet und angesagt sind heute, das ist
React, Vue.js und Angular, das sind so die drei großen Dinger
ich persönlich finde Vue.js am angenehmsten
vielleicht war es auch das, weil ich
das hauptsächlich benutze und damit jetzt auch mal angefangen habe das zu lernen
ähm
aber das sind so die drei großen aktuell
selbst Bootstrap hat kein jQuery mehr mittlerweile
Buch wie switcht du so instant zwischen Windows 10 und deiner Linux
Control
Windows, Taste, File links, File rechts
das ist Windows Desktop
mit einer Fullscreen Linux VM auf dem zweiten Desktop
und dann habe ich natürlich noch unterschiedliche desktops in der Linux VM
weil man kann nie
genug desktops haben
also ich würde sagen, um nochmal zu den aktuellen Frameworks zu sagen
von der Verbreitung her würde ich aktuell sagen, ist React vorne
gefolgt von
Chat was meint ihr, was ist verbreitet, Angular oder Vue?
Vue war eine Zeit lang so ein bisschen underdog, ist aber voll explodiert
aber React ist auf jeden Fall vorne
Angular
React, Angular, Vue.js
würde ich auch so sagen
und so Sachen wie Svelte und so cool sind, sind halt noch mehr Nische, es gibt ja noch
viel mehr Frameworks in der Richtung
ähm
das sind aber auf jeden Fall die drei großen, man macht eigentlich mit keinem wirklich was
falsch
die Philosophien sind ein bisschen anders
in JavaScript kommt wirklich jede Sekunde ein neues Framework
die Philosophien sind halt ein bisschen anders
Angular hat halt
alles irgendwie built-in
und so den Angular-Way, wie man was verwenden kann
React hat fast nichts dabei
ist dafür halt sehr pluginlastig und modular und man kann halt nur das verwenden, was man will
und Vue.js ist eigentlich ein richtig cooles Mittelding
es ist alles dabei oder es gibt mehr oder weniger offizielle Packages für
alles wichtige, was man braucht
es gibt aber auch viele Plugins
und ich finde es am angenehmst zu verwenden
aber wie gesagt
für so Kleinkram hier
dass das schöne an Vue.js ist übrigens, dass man das ein bisschen verwenden kann wie JQuery
das hier ist eine ganz normale HTML-Seite
und ich habe einfach hier Vue included und man kann es verwenden
das kannst du mit den anderen nicht machen, wobei bei React ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
bei React kannst du es wahrscheinlich auch machen
hat Angular und React auch One-Way-Binding, ich habe keine Ahnung von Angular und React
achso und eine Sache, warum React auch noch relativ verbreitet ist
weil die Leute
gerne Handy-Anwendungen mit React machen
Smartphone-Anwendungen
aber überhaupt
ihr glaubt gar nicht
wie viele Anwendungen auf eurem Android oder auf eurem IOS-Gerät
unter der Haube verkappte Web-Anwendungen sind
ich würde mal sagen 80%
jetzt mal Spiele außen vor, aber 80% ist jetzt einfach mal so ein Bauchgefühl, ich habe keine Ahnung ob es stimmt
80%
der Apps im App-Store
sind Webseiten verpackt als App
so also wo sind wir denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben? Ich habe jetzt hier einen URL
und die ändert sich auch immer
es ist immer die gleiche, es ist ein leeres Bild
Leute das funktioniert nicht, was mache ich denn verkehrt
was mache ich jetzt verkehrt, warum kriege ich hier
warum kriege ich hier kein
warum kriege ich da kein Bild gemalt?
war ich verkehrt?
also es ist immer das gleiche hier
das kann nicht sein
ach hier guckt mal ich Kacknoob
das gibt es doch gar nicht
ah jetzt sieht das doch schon besser aus
529kb so ein Bild, ja das ist ihn das ist ihn
ok das kommt hin
ok sehr gut
naja weil jQuery
zumindest das reine manipulieren von
Webseiten recht einfach macht
ich muss dir aber ehrlich sagen
ich würde wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch wenn es um solche einfachen Sachen geht
Vue.js verwenden, weil wie gesagt
man kann es auch
Track and Drop, Replace
in die Seite einbauen
und ich finde es angenehmer
aber wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen will, wie Webseiten aufgebaut
sind, wie das mit der Dommer und den Elementen und so funktioniert
ist es vielleicht mit jQuery doch gar nicht verkehrt
also ich habe jetzt hier ein Bild, kann ich das Bild jetzt hier wenigstens reinpappen?
Canvas to all, geht das?
erkennt er das als Bild?
wahrscheinlich nicht
wie mache ich daraus jetzt, wie mache ich daraus denn jetzt ein Bild?
wir gucken mal ob die irgendwas haben was Data, Data URLs oder so nimmt
Moment, nee, wir müssen mal das Richtige aufmachen
Ne, da gibt es anscheinend nichts anderes
was hatte der Typ hier vorhin?
Canvas Image
muss man mal kurz ein bisschen
ordentliche Doku haben die da anscheinend nicht für Canvas Image
was haben wir denn hier?
Get Image Data
Okay
Get Color
Source Image Quality
Okay, irgendwie gibt es da nichts Asynchrones oder was, was mit Urls geht
Get Color from Url, das klingt schon mal gut
Ob wir da das reinpacken können?
Moment, das muss ich erst mal ausbrechen
Wie ruft man das auch?
Get Color from Url
Und dann Image Url Callback Quality, okay Callback, Callback machen wir
Excellent
Und Quality 10 war bei dem anderen drin
Und dann gibt es Callback mit zwei Parametern, okay
Dann mal schauen ob da irgendwas zurückkommt
Also falls irgendjemand eine Idee hat, wie ich daraus ein ordentliches Bild machen kann
was das frisst, immer nur zu
Schauen wir mal ob das so geht
Ach ne, Moment, ich muss ja auch nicht Canvas, ich muss ja auch sagen
Get Image Data
Du brauchst einen Image Tag, ja aber wie macht man das hier ohne dass ich das jetzt
irgendwie
Moment
Geht das jetzt?
Okay, hat sich gerade erledigt, es funktioniert auch so
Also 63, 65, 62
Was ist denn das für eine Farbe, RGB, Color
Irgendwas, also 63, 65, 62, was grünes, ne was graus
Okay, das ist die Primary Color von diesem Bild hier
Na gut, kann schon sein, je nachdem was das eben für ein Bild war, aber das ändert sich
ja schon ganz schön
Je nachdem was das für ein Bild ist
Okay, also was der jetzt hier rausbekommt ist die Prime, also die am meisten verwendete
Farbe in diesem Bild und das ist immer diese jeweils
Jetzt müsste was grünes sein jetzt, hier das, warte mal
Das gucken wir uns jetzt eben an, das müsste was grünes sein wie dieses Gras hier unten
Hatten die bei Google nicht was Gutes, doch hier, bam
Ja, guck mal, das kommt hin
Das kommt hin, von der Grasfarbe her
Okay, also, jetzt heißt wir bekommen das Ganze jetzt zurück, das funktioniert, schonmal nice
Wahrscheinlich ist das optimierungstechnisch fragwürdig, wenn ich da jedesmal ein neues
Canvas erzeuge und jedesmal das Bild male
Mal schauen, mal schauen
Oh, jetzt kommt Javascript Big Brain
Wie mach ich denn da ein Promise draus, wie geht denn das
Weil ich will das ja awaiten und so, so geht das nicht
Jo, Promise
Also ich brauch irgendwas, auf was ich warten kann
Auf was ich nicht warten kann, auf was ich asynchron warten kann
Und das ist ja den Wert, den ich zurückgeben will
Ich brauch ein Beispiel
Was, Return, Promise, Resolve und dann
Aha, Return you Promise, ja sowas, genau sowas, genau sowas, Phoenix
Ja, ich kann nicht einfach Await verwenden
Weil sich das hier nicht Awaiten lässt, muss ich jetzt was draus bauen, was sich Awaiten
lässt
Also, was war das, Resolve
Moment, kann der hier das
Irgendein, irgendein Makro, Resolve und was war das andere, Reject, sagt der Chat
Und dann sowas hier
Und dann
Resolve
Äh, äh, was, was war das eben
Ah, ah
Ok, RGB und hier das
Discarden wir mal
Mal ob das jetzt funktioniert, ob da jetzt RGB Werte rauskommen
Achso, die Resolve RGB
Ja, funktioniert, sehr gut
Warum machst du eine Funktion, die hat doch nicht nur synchrone Sachen
Naja, gut
Na, weil ich das zurückgeben will, wie soll ich das sonst gescheit machen
Das hier ist ein Callback und wenn ich sage, Return den Wert, dann returnt der bevor der
Callback ausgeführt ist, wahrscheinlich
Weil ich will ja hier unten sagen
So, RGB
Das funktioniert ja anders nicht
Weil jetzt habe ich hier unten die RGB Werte für drin stehen, kann ich weitermachen mit
So, ok, jetzt haben wir die RGB Werte schon mal ganz gut
Jetzt kann ich mal ausprobieren, ob das prinzipiell von der Farbe hier hinkommt
Das wird jetzt zwar sehr schlecht
Äh, sehr schlecht gleich sichtbar sein der Rahmen, aber das ist Absicht
Also brauchen wir Stroke Style, ist nicht Black, sondern
Kann man da sowas machen?
Kann man da CSS Functions drin verwenden, sowas hier?
Geht das?
Mal ausprobieren
Äh, ne, anscheinend gehts nicht, ok
Oh, doch, funktioniert
Ab bloß nix erkannt
Ok, also RGB
RGB, RGB, exzellent, ne, das muss man jetzt noch einsetzen
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht als Array, sondern als String, hör
Oh, ne, das geht doch einfach, guck mal, easy, funktioniert
Der malt jetzt den Kasten in der Farbe, in der hauptsächlich, also der Kasten wird in
der Farbe gemalt, das was die dominante Color von dem Bild ist
Und das kommt hin, das kommt hin, ich mein, das ist ja genau das was ich nicht machen will
Ich will ja das invertierte davon malen, also weil das man es besser sieht, weil so sieht
es ja kein Mensch gerade, aber guck, mit der Farbe erkennt man das schon
Person, Person, ja
Ja, das scheint zu funktionieren
Exzellent, wie schnell ist denn das, lass mal kurz gucken, wie lang das, was das überhaupt
für, ähm, was das überhaupt zieht, äh, wie macht man das irgendwie so
Jetzt, aber das hab ich doch sogar in der Demo eben gesehen von dem Typ
Kann ich irgendwas mal daten?
Performance Now, oh, was ist denn das, das Big Brain JavaScript Zeug
Der in Millisekunden gemesselt, der auf 5 Mikrosekunden genau ist, ah, yes
Und wie funktioniert das, ah, aha, aha, aha, man lernt nie aus, man lernt nie
Performance Now, Wahnsinn, äh, warum mach ich das einen Start drin, ich muss das da unten
drin machen, äh, T1, T2, und jetzt kann ich sagen, ähm, T2 minus T1, oder so, oder?
Äh, ah, ja 100, was, was denn 100, Millisekunden, das Millisekunden, Millisekunden, ah nice,
okay, das heißt so ein Bild zu erkennen dauert irgendwie, sagen wir mal so im Durchschnitt
so 75 Millisekunden, das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, weil
ich nur alle 2 Sekunden ein Bild hab, passt, super, gar kein Ding, man könnte das wahrscheinlich
sogar noch optimieren, indem man irgendwie dieses Canvas hier nur einmal anlegen lässt
und das nächste Mal wieder verwendet oder so, aber mal draufgeschissen, also das ist
okay, also 50, 60, 70 Millisekunden ist überhaupt gar kein Problem, der macht ja nur alle 2
Sekunden was, hast du mal was mit Haskell gemacht, nein, das, die einzige funktionale
Programmiersprache, wo ich mal ein bisschen was drin gemacht hab, also ein bisschen mit
rumgeschwürt war F-Sharp und halt, äh, Emacs, Lisp, aber das ist auch abartig, was hab
ich, hab ich was zu viel gelöscht gerade, okay, jetzt kommt der nächste, jetzt, jetzt
wird's, jetzt kommt der nächste Sache, wie invertiere ich diese, wobei, ist invertieren
überhaupt das richtige Wort, wie nennt man das denn, wie nennt man das denn, wenn man,
ich suche die Farbe, die am besten sichtbar ist auf dieser Farbe, wie nennt man das denn,
komplementär, ah, genau, exellent, exquisite chat, okay, rgb, kom, wie heißt das eigentlich,
wie, wahrscheinlich, kom, komplementär, wie berechnet man das, ich brauch ein Javascript-Beispiel,
was es ist, rgb 255 minus, oh, das glaub ich nicht, dass das geht, weil das hier ist, wir
können's mal ausprobieren, das hier ist ja CSS, wie, ich mein, ich kann's mal ausprobieren,
man weiß ja nie, also ich fürchte, das funktioniert nicht, nein, ach so, komponentenweise, also
sprich, sprich, du meinst, also sag mal, let red gleich rgb 1, also rgb 0, sowas hier meinst
du, hopp, und was, was macht das dann, ja okay, mal angenommen, das ist 1, dann ist
es 200, hey, die Idee ist gar nicht schlecht, das könnte richtig gut funktionieren, also
green, blue, guck, ob das jetzt klappt, so, dann sagen wir rgb gleich red, green, blue,
ah, naja, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, das ist gar nicht mal so verkehrt, ah, ja, das
ist so, das ist so, ich bin ja auch blöd, warum mach ich denn das hier unten, was mach
ich denn hier, das, was mach ich in der Schleife da, ich will das gar nicht in der Schleife
machen, ich will das einmal fürs ganze Bild machen, lull, ja, die casten Timeout noch
nicht richtig, das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut, muss ich sagen, das ist gar nicht mal
schlecht, wird das, das ist gar nicht übel, also man kann es an der Stelle auf jeden fall
besser sehen als den schwarzen casten, da jetzt ist es fragwürdig, hast du da eins
gesehen, äh, nee, oh, oh, das ist eine gute Idee, timmy, das ist eine gute Idee, also
einmal lgb, ist das, ist map in place oder muss ich das so machen, muss ich das so machen
oder kann ich das weglassen, ok, ja nice, ok, das geht schon mal in die Richtung, wie
ich mir das vorstelle, jetzt, ok, dann stoppen wir das mal und probieren das mal mit dem
Nachtbild aus, weil dieses Pokemon Bild ist ja nur wirklich nicht unbedingt das, was
man bei der security camera hat, zeig mal her, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
machen wir das ganze Bild, wir wollen ja gar nicht das ganze Bild, wir wollen ja eigentlich
nur wissen wie man diesen Ausschnitt einfärben muss, am besten, also sprich wir machen nicht
das gesamte Bild, sondern wir machen sowas hier in die in der Richtung hier x, y, ojajaja
genau das machen wir, das ist exzellent, exzellent, exzellent, ehm, geh mal den Kram hier runter
kopieren, wo hab ich hier start stopp, also was brauchen wir dafür, was brauchen wir
dafür, wir brauchen start x, y, das ist left und top, top ist y, dann brauchen wir breite
und höhe, ich muss mal aufs Klo, ich will jetzt erstmal probieren ob das funktioniert,
und dann sagen, wo kann man das jetzt hier einfügen, da vielleicht, haben wir hier noch
für Möglichkeiten, x, y, ah guck mal hier source x, source y, source width, source height,
destination brauchen wir nicht, also von der Idee her brauche ich dann sowas hier, x, y,
ehm, wie haben die das genannt, sw, sy, weil grün haben wir schon, sy, sowas, jetzt sollte
der, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht vertan hab, sollte er den Bereich nehmen den ich eh umrahmen
will, das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt ein bisschen dunklere Farbe oder als vorher, seh ich das
richtig, ein ticken dunkler ist es, ehm, wisst ihr was wir auch, ich hab noch eine andere,
die wisst ihr was wir auch machen können, das hier ist jetzt ja recht dynamisch, also
sprich, ehm, der nimmt immer, was ist denn 255, ist 255 schwarz, ne, also 0 ist weiß
und 255 schwarz, oder umgedreht, ich kann mich jetzt immer nicht merken, ich glaub 255
schwarz und 0 ist weiß, ehm, andersrum, na gut, also sprich der nimmt komplett weiß und zieht
immer den Wert davon ab, ja Moment, dann funktioniert das aber doch nicht sonderlich gut oder, weil,
wenn ich eine Farbe hab, die fast schon weiß ist, dann würde er ja auch fast ein weißes
Rechteck malen, das funktioniert doch dann gar nicht, könnte ich nicht sowas hier machen,
wenn C größer ist als, keine Ahnung, größer gleich 128, dann machen wir es, ehm, dann
machen wir es schwarz und ansonsten machen wir es weiß, irgendwie so, ist nicht auch
ordentlich funktionieren, ah, ah, ach, exzellent, warum nicht ein Kasten in pink, das wäre zu
einfach, warum sollte ich den Kasten immer in der gleichen Farbe malen, die gut sichtbar
ist, anstatt den Kasten dynamisch anzupassen, dynamisch anzupassen ist viel mehr unser
Style, oder chat, dynamisch anpassen, also ich meine, gleichfarbigen Kasten malen kann
ja jeder, yes, und ein bisschen Rechenleistung von Endgeräten verschwenden kann man auch,
auch ok, warum dann nicht gleich rare parrot und in farbe, das ist eine gute Idee, ich
weiß allerdings nicht wie man GIFs malt, das finde ich ziemlich gut, das ist wirklich
gut lesbar, ne, das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir echt, echt gut, wir machen jetzt nur noch
das Label komplett groß, ehm, to uppercase ist es in Javascript, oder, uppercase, fangen
wir das Label nochmal groß, doch, doch, das gefällt mir jetzt schon ziemlich gut, das
hat was, das hat was, das ist doch nice jetzt, oder, oder ist person schon ein bisschen groß,
person ist schon ein bisschen fett, oder, bisschen sick, einfach mal 18 machen, ok
wir gucken jetzt mal wie es auf dem anderen, wie es jetzt mit dem anderen Video aussehen
würde, mit dem Pokemon Video, das ist weiß, ja ok erkennt man trotzdem, ja ja, blau, wie
kann das blau sein, Leute wie kann das blau sein, wie kann da blau rauskommen, wie kann
da blau rauskommen, ich setze das entweder auf weiß oder auf schwarz, wie kommt da blau
raus, wie, wie konnte da überhaupt blau rauskommen eben, what the fuck, ich hab die
Auswahl zwischen komplett weiß und komplett schwarz, warum kommt da blau raus, ah ich
machs für jede einzelne Farbe, das stimmt, ah verstehe, ja natürlich, ja, stimmt, du
hast recht, du hast recht, es kann ja so, was ist das da oben, what the fuck, da kann
ja sowas rauskommen wie weiß, weiß, schwarz, oder, oder, oder, oder, schwarz, weiß, ja
da kann schon blau rauskommen, ja das stimmt, das sind die einzelnen Kanäle, genau, ja,
ok mit mehreren Sachen ist es ein bisschen fail, muss ich ehrlich sagen, da weiß ich
nicht, ob mir das so gut gefällt, jetzt wieder blau, vielleicht machen wir es doch pink,
ok wir machen mal das fitness, das fitness Video kurz, ich, und dann gehe ich mal kurz
aufs Klo, wir machen mal kurz den fitness Dude wieder, achso das ist eine andere Auflösung,
da muss ich neu starten, ah ne, oder auch nicht, ok doch die Auflösung ist falsch,
ich hab nix gesagt Leute, die Auflösung ist falsch, das ist, eine Kamera kann nicht
im laufenden Stream ihre Auflösung ändern, das mag er nicht, das machen normale Kameras
hier auch nicht, wow, MonkaS, an sich ist es schon ganz nice, aber das wechsel, ne, ne,
ne, das gefällt mir doch nicht so genau, ah ne, das gefällt mir nicht, machen wir mal
kurz den Kram hier weg, keck weh, hab ich, hab ich vielleicht hier Mist drin, wobei das
mit der, mit der color passt schon, schneide ich das hier vielleicht falsch aus, so Leute
ich geh jetzt mal aufs Klo, ich muss mal, ich muss mal dringend, Pruder muss groß,
das ist jetzt, hallo, exzellent, so, ähm, Chat, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, was machen wir denn?
Irgendwas an, einfach mal laufen, ich geh mal aufs Klo kurz.
So, das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute.
Danke für's Zuschauen.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
So, bevor wir weitermachen, Leute.
Residenz Leaper, ja.
Bevor wir weitermachen, gucken wir uns jetzt mal eine
Grunde aktuelle Amazon-Angebote an.
Ich brauche hier an mir, womit du deine Kameras mit niedriger Verzögerung im Browser streamen kannst und was dann guckt, ob Leute im Bild zu sehen sind und dann rückwinkend die letzten 10 Sekunden aufnimmt plus dann 30 Sekunden.
Ich versuche gerade das dynamisch anzupassen, wie dieser Rahmen gemalt wird, je nachdem, was für eine Farbe im Bild verwendet wird.
Aber...
Das gefällt mir noch nicht so richtig gut, ehrlich gesagt.
Ah, Moment!
Nee, ich mach's ja eh neu.
Wo hast du das Ganze gelernt?
Es gibt nicht einen Punkt, wo ich das gelernt habe.
Über die letzten Jahre hat man sich das halt so in unterschiedlichsten Sachen angeeignet.
Und dann passt das jetzt ganz gut zusammen.
Also, C-Sharp habe ich schon gelernt seit 2004 oder 2005 oder so.
Ist auch nach wie vor meine Lieblingssprache, witzigerweise.
Es ist ja oft mal so, dass man die Sachen, womit man anfängt, nicht so toll findet nach einer Zeit.
Aber C-Sharp war so die erste Programmiersprache, wo ich richtig viel drin gemacht habe.
Immer noch meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache.
Learning by doing, genau.
Das ist auch das, was ich Leute immer sage, wenn ich gefragt werde, wie lernt man am besten programmieren?
Am einfachsten, wenn man weiß, was man machen will und sich dann ein bisschen da langhangelt, weil dann sieht man auch, dass es was bringt.
Dass man der Sache, die man machen will, näher kommt.
Das motiviert dann am meisten.
Guck mal, es gibt SSDs zu kaufen.
Gibt es denn mittlerweile schon 4TB Samsung EVO NVMe?
Immer noch nicht. Wann gibt es die denn endlich mal?
Wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner baue, will ich einen 4TB NVMe haben.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Warum gibt es noch keine 4TB?
Ja, so welche gibt es da. Warum gibt es noch keine Samsung EVO NVMe?
Was hindert Samsung daran, so etwas zu bauen?
Ja, warum gibt es das noch nicht?
Wann gibt es denn das?
Nee, das ist irgendwas anderes.
Diversiert bist du mit Datenbank gedürnt, nicht wirklich.
Also Datenbank ist nicht so gerade meine Spezialität.
Kommt natürlich drauf an, was du wissen willst, ja.
So, also was haben die für SSDs im Angebot?
SSDs lohnen sich manchmal.
Davon habe ich schon welche, die sind kacke langsam.
Die droppen irgendwann auf 120 MB Schreiben runter.
Nee, von Oracle habe ich keine Ahnung.
Das MX500, Terabyte.
Gut, lass mal überlegen, brauche ich für irgendwas aktuell eine SSD?
Eigentlich nicht, ich habe mittlerweile wirklich nur schon mehr als genug SSDs überall drin.
Für neuen Rechner aber.
Eine SSD Marke würdest du empfehlen, ganz ehrlich, ich habe fast nur Samsung.
Und dann habe ich von denen nochmal eine 2TB glaube ich.
Aber ansonsten, ich habe fast nur Samsung SSDs.
2T.
Das hat jetzt mit SSD aber nicht allzu viel, achso, da ist noch RAM dabei.
RAM brauche ich erst rechnernd.
Ich habe mehr als genug, ich habe mehr RAM, als ich überhaupt brauche im Rechner drin.
Was erzählst du von so Mainstream, von was?
Spezialisierten Seiten wie Doktor, Windows, Abfilter, Mobile, lese ich überhaupt nicht, keine Ahnung.
Einzige Sache, wo ich manchmal lese, ist China Gadgets.
Was es mal wieder bei Banggood und AliExpress günstiges zu bestellen gibt.
Ne, aber das lese ich nicht, ich kann dazu gar nicht sagen, ob die gut oder schlecht werden.
Ich weiß es schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Aber Doktor Windows klingt schon irgendwie ziemlich PC Welt Niveau.
Also es gab Super Mario Hausschuhe, Poggers, Piranha Pflanze Hausschuhe, exzellent.
Sehen ja auch schon sehr hochwertig aus.
Und was da drin steckt, sieht auch überhaupt nicht nach Photoshop Füßen aus oder so.
Lass mal, lass noch mal kurz hier das Amazon Zeug weiter durchgucken.
Was haben wir denn so, was gibt es denn heute im Smart Home Bereich?
Das ist eigentlich die einzige Sache, die ich wirklich täglich mir angucke.
Baumarkt ist manchmal auch ganz interessant.
PS5 oder neue Xbox?
Ich werde mir keins von beiden jetzt zu Release holen.
Ich habe den großen Fehler gemacht, nur PS4 und Xbox Series X zu holen.
Ne, Xbox wäre immer die letzte, die hieß Xbox One, Schwachsinn.
Zu Release zu holen und ich habe beides so gut wie gar nicht verwendet.
Hier, das können wir zumachen.
So, das ist doch immer noch der gleiche Kram, den es gestern auch gab.
Das ist doch genau, das haben wir uns doch gestern schon lustig gemacht,
dass es irgendwelche Boomer Telefone bei Amazon gibt.
Das ist doch noch genau exakt der gleiche Kram wie gestern.
Was ist denn das?
Was soll denn das sein?
Ein kleines LED.
Warum nicht einfach eine Lampe?
Oh ja, das brauche ich unbedingt Music Sync, ganz wichtig.
Ja, Xbox-Namen blickt man echt nicht mehr durch.
Also das ist ganz abenteuerlich gemacht von Microsoft.
Also Sachen benennen können sie nicht.
Das ist der gleiche Mist wie gestern, immer noch.
SemiSmart, exzellenten Namen.
SemiSmart.
SemiSmart habe ich noch nie, der Name ist witzig, was haben die denn?
Oh, was ist denn das?
Ein Vorhang-Bewegungs-Ding.
Und das funktioniert?
Aber was für einen Preis, Alter.
174 Euro für ein Rollladen-Bewegungs-Ding.
Das ist mir ein bisschen teuer, ehrlich gesagt.
Haben die denn ein Video oder so, wie das funktioniert?
Das sieht nämlich nicht sonderlich hochwertig aus, auf den ersten Blick.
Ich habe von denen noch nie was gehört.
Was ist das?
SemiSmart.
Ist das so SemiSmart mit Z?
Das ist genauso wie der eine Hersteller, wo wir letztens da hatten, Gosund.
Da habe ich auch noch nie was von gehört.
Auch 100.000 Sachen, aber alles nur rebrandet, irgendwelche China-Dinger.
Wie heißt Gosund, wenn sie kein Corona haben?
Gesund.
Krasser Joke, ich weiß.
Was haben wir jetzt hier noch als nächstes?
Pains-Jab, aber richtig Pains-Jab.
Blind-Engine-Smart-Wi-Fi-Motor-Controlled-Pliance.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Starke Schmerzen hier, aber echt.
Das ist wirklich Pains-Jab.
Canvas-LED-Touch-Panel-Set.
Was macht man damit?
Das finde ich irgendwie ganz cool.
Hol dir eine Samsung Evo, die Kosten mehr sind, aber top.
Mit was steuert man das?
Kann man das flaschen, irgendwie?
Clocks HD, moin.
Kann man das flaschen?
Ungeflasht zackt.
Nanoleaf.
Oder gibt es Nanoleaf für Home Assistant?
Nanoleaf für Home Assistant.
Man kann das komplett offline über Home Assistant steuern.
Moment.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Hat das nicht eben irgendwie...
Ach so.
Leute, ich habe gedacht, das kostet irgendwie 21 Euro oder so.
Ich habe mich da voll verguckt.
194, nee.
Also, das beim besten Willen nicht.
194.
Lohnen sich Samsung Evos mehr als Cuvo für den Mehrpreis?
Ja, ist halt die Frage, was es mehr kostet.
In der Regel sind die Evos deutlich besser, auch wenn du kontinuierlich drauf schreibst.
Also nicht, ob sie nicht wegen kaputt gehen und nicht, sondern...
Ich meine, das auch, aber das macht jetzt nicht wirklich aus,
sondern wie lange die beispielsweise ihre maximale Schreibgeschwindigkeit aufrechterhalten können und so was.
Ja, mit so neun Dreiecken kommt man gar nicht hin.
Ich meine, guck mal hier.
Bis du das hier gemacht hast, dann eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun.
Bis dahin kommste mit neun.
Zehn, elf, zwölf, dreizehn.
Neun zwanzig brauchste, das heißt, du brauchst quasi...
Alter!
Sechshundert Euro für diese Wand!
What the fuck?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Leute, nee.
Wirklich nett, nee.
Was ich ja ganz cool fand, das Schlafzimmer, was die gezeigt haben oder was das war.
Wo so an die Decke hoch ist, das da.
What the fuck?
Viel zu teuer.
Du hast doch einen 3D-Drucker, ja und?
Damit krieg ich zwar das Plastik gedruckt, aber...
Ich hab keine Steuerung, ich hab keine LEDs, die dazu passen.
Nee, ich glaub, sowas baut man ungünstig selbst.
Gibt's das vielleicht günstiger?
Ich hab das noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Viel zu teuer, Alter.
Guck mal mal.
Ja, ich verschreibe mich bei dem Ding auch immer.
Force-Champ.
Ha!
Okay.
Und da steht auch drin, was man braucht.
Hm.
Okay, also das Ausdrucken ist klar.
Und dann kommt hier so ein Strip.
Was verwendet der Typ?
Software Instructions und GitHub.
Wem musst du... Hab ich massig da?
Ein WS2812B-LED-Strip.
Aliexpress will mir nicht sagen, was das kostet.
Ah, hier.
1, hier 2, 2, 59 kostet's.
Okay, das lohnt sich in der Tat, das selbst zu bauen.
Das lohnt sich in der Tat, das selbst zu bauen.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, das hier aus einem 3D-Drucker auszudrucken,
ist ja wirklich kein Problem.
Und wenn das schon quasi Firmware und so alles fertig ist,
eigentlich ne wirklich coole Sache.
Eigentlich ne ziemlich coole Idee.
Das gefällt mir wirklich gut.
Ich bin da mal geneigt, mal was zu bestellen.
Ups.
Warum kann ich jetzt nicht wieder vorwärts?
Was sind denn das für Strips?
Welches Strips sind das WS?
Mal gucken, was die bei Amazon kosten.
Hier, IP 30, gibt's IP 30 White.
Leute, habt ihr ne gute Idee für nen LED-Strip für den Weihnachtsbaum?
Ich hab aktuell sowas hier in der Richtung für den Weihnachtsbaum.
Hab ich euch ja letztes Jahr mal auf Twitter gezeigt.
Schaut mal auf.
Was ich noch finden.
Aber ich glaub, ich find mal nen Tweet nicht mehr.
Wobei ich kann mal bei Media gucken, da müsste man es eigentlich finden.
Alter Login.
Ich hab's hier letztes Jahr in Dezember gepostet.
Wird nicht so schwer zu finden sein.
Schon im April, März, Februar, Januar, Januar.
Hier, da.
Also bitte jetzt nicht weiter über diesen wahnsinnigen Weihnachtsbaum herziehen.
Das haben wir letztes Jahr zu Genüge gemacht.
Ich weiß, Massive Huge Baum.
Aber hier ist das Strip.
Ich bin damit nicht ganz zufrieden gewesen mit dem LED-Strip.
Weil die LEDs waren RGB.
Die waren nicht RGBW.
Das heißt, die hatten kein schönes Weiß.
Und das Kabel war ein bisschen dick.
Hat da einer eine gute Empfehlung für nen LED-Strip, der für Weihnachten sich eignet?
Okay, kommt die Handy-Steuerung.
Alles selbst programmiert.
Man kann es auch weiß machen.
Da sieht man, dass es kein richtiges Weiß hat, sondern eher sowas Blaues.
Die Tischstärke ist on point. Richtig on point.
Und irgendwo da hinten steht mein Raspberry Pi rum.
Also der eine unten wird geschossen.
Ja.
Sowas ähnliches habe ich da dran, aber das gefällt mir nicht so wirklich.
5 Volt, 50 Stück.
Lieferung bis 24. November.
Das ist Dienstag.
Leute, was meint ihr, wie viele Videos ich schon für den Adventskalender aufgenommen habe?
Ich sag's euch, ich glaube irgendwie vier, fünf Stück oder so.
Nein, es sind nicht ganz null. Ich hab tatsächlich schon was aufgenommen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich das auf die Reihe bekomme, da wirklich 24 Videos zu machen.
Ich glaube, es ist besser. Ich mach einfach vielleicht nur 10 Videos,
aber dann halt über den 10. Dezember verteilt.
Der Chat hat Vertrauen. Der Chat weiß einfach, wie es ist.
Ich kenn mich ja und ich hätte auch auf null getippt.
Sind die RGB oder RGBW?
Was ist WS2812B?
Was ist denn da drinnen? RGB.
Nee, die sind RGBW. Guckt mal, oder?
Nee, sie sind RGB.
Aber es sind 5 Volt. Okay, 5 Volt ist gut.
5 Volt kann man nämlich schön am Controller direkt betreiben.
Irgendwie tendiere ich dazu, mir mal so einen Strip zu holen.
Wie sind denn die Strips? So kann man die einfach durchschneiden?
Weil es gibt ja Strips, die kann man einfach durchschneiden an der Stelle, wo man sie nicht mehr braucht.
Und dann, okay.
Also was hat er hier geschrieben? Recommended.
Ein, at least 60 LEDs pro Meter. Also die hier empfiehlt er.
Aber 2899 geht vollkommen in Ordnung.
5 Meter 60 LEDs pro Meter. Das geht voll klar.
Bestell mir da jetzt einen.
Der 90 Watt für den ganzen Strip.
5 Volt ist top.
Als Netzteil werde ich wahrscheinlich das Ding hier verwenden.
Da habe ich nämlich noch ein paar Rumfliegen. So was Ähnliches hier ist das.
Die machen 3 bis 12 Volt. Was haben die maximal?
Output.
Oh, 1000 milliampere. Da kommen wir nicht so weit.
Da kommen wir vielleicht mit einem Meter, oder?
Oh, maximal 1000 milliampere. Da kommen wir nicht weit. 1 Ampere mit 12 Volt.
Da kommen wir vielleicht gerade mal mit einem Strip.
Einmal muss alles selbst ab. Das stört mich nicht.
In welchem DSP Tool? Was gibt es denn da für ein ordentliches Netzteil?
Das habe ich dafür mal angenommen. Okay, ob das wirklich 90 Watt braucht?
Das wird dann auch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen warm.
Gibt es denn ordentliches 5 Volt?
So ein Ding will ich mir da eigentlich nicht hinlegen.
Kennst du eine günstige Lösung ohne Löten, die nicht Philips oder Co. heißt?
Für was denn? Für RGB Lichter?
Also mit Strips kenne ich mich nicht so aus. Das bin ich gerade überlegen zu kaufen.
Also ich habe die hier, aber die sind nicht günstig.
Ich habe die hier, weil Philips Hue ist auch absolut nicht mein Fall.
Wifi.
Es gibt aber ein schönes Video, was ich dir empfehlen kann.
Und zwar der hier hat einen guten Vergleich von RGB Lampen gemacht.
Das da. Die zwei Videos kannst du dir mal angucken.
Dann stellt er unterschiedlich teure Sachen vor und zeigt dir auch die Farben davon.
Die Videos fand ich gut, die zwei.
Ja, die kann man sich mal angucken.
Okay, also sagen wir mal so, ich werde wahrscheinlich nicht 5 Meter dran machen an einen Controller,
sondern wahrscheinlich eher zweieinhalb an den einen und zweieinhalb an den anderen.
Aber trotzdem gibt es denn, gibt es irgendwelche Netzteile, die ich nehmen könnte?
Das sind 5 Volt, 18 Ampere.
Ja, gut.
Das reicht.
USB Fast Charger, genau die.
Weil wie gesagt, die Dinger hier, die habe ich ja für Weihnachtsbaum, aber auch die 5 Volt Variante.
Ich brauche nichts und das habe ich an dem einen Netzteil dran, das juckt die überhaupt nicht.
Aber diese Netzteile sind ja so offen, die sind bestimmt nicht dafür gedacht,
einfach so irgendwo hinzuschmeißen.
Die sollte man bestimmt irgendwo dahinter machen dann.
Das sind wieder andere Strips.
Nee, das sind die gleichen Strips.
IP 30, weiß IP 30.
Und die haben auch 1 Meter 144 LEDs, Poggers.
Okay, das macht dann halt heller, aber ich glaube, das braucht man nicht wirklich, oder?
Erkennt sich da mit jemand aus?
Lohnt nicht, ja.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube, ich werde mir mal sowas bilden.
Und wie schließt man die Dinger an?
Hier kommt die Steckdose dran.
Da hier links.
Input.
Da kommt die Steckdose dran.
Ah, man kann da auch 2 Sachen abgreifen von dem Netzteil, wobei 1 ist egal, ich kann da auch einfach 2 reinklemmen.
Das heißt, ich könnte auch an einem Netzteil mehrere Strips betreiben.
Gibt es da nicht irgendwas, was man in die Steckdose steckt, was schon fertig ist?
Sowas hier quasi.
Das für ein hässliches Teil, Alter.
MonkaS für den Zigarettenanzünder.
Ja, einen Ambilight habe ich auch.
Aber kein Ambilight, sondern einen Fake Ambilight.
Ich werde mir das auf jeden Fall mal kopieren, davon bestelle ich mir jetzt mal einen Strip.
Das hier die gleichen, die ich hier offen habe.
Ah, Moment, das sind unterschiedliche.
Das ist Eco und das ist...
Ist da ein Unterschied dazwischen?
WSBALL, WS12B.
Die Namen sind wieder absolut geil, Alter.
Okay, das kopiere ich mir mal rüber.
Da bestelle ich mir nachher mal eine Runde.
Ich habe eh echt Bock, ein bisschen Weihnachtsbeleuchtung zu machen mit RGB Strips.
Und da programmiere ich den Controller lieber selbst.
Und vielleicht drucke ich mir echt so ein Teil hier aus.
Ich finde, das ist eine richtig coole Sache.
Das wäre auch ein cooles Video für Weihnachten.
Das gefällt mir.
Zumal, die haben ja halt eine Bauanleitung drinnen.
Das sah jetzt nicht sonderlich kompliziert aus.
Also man braucht die Strips.
Man braucht...
Das braucht man, genau, das braucht man.
Das habe ich auch gedacht, dass man das braucht.
Braucht man aber nicht.
Zumindest nicht mit dem NodeMCU-Ding.
Ja, so ein Netzteil, so ein fertiges Netzteil wäre mir ehrlich gesagt auch am liebsten.
Da mache ich mich mal nachher schlau.
Das ist jetzt nichts, was wir uns hier im Stream angucken müssen.
Aber wie baut man das denn zusammen?
Assemble, okay, zack, zack, Löcher.
Für die Löcher kann ich hier meine Thread-In-Dinger benutzen, die man mit Lötkolben reinschmilzt.
Willst du denn dein eigenes Nanoleaf drucken?
Ja, zumindest gucke ich mir gerade die Sachen.
Wo baut man es denn zusammen?
Ach, hier sind die Strips.
Hier in die Ecke ein paar LEDs, da in die Ecke ein paar LEDs.
Das sieht jetzt nicht so kompliziert aus zu bauen.
Alter, Yukara, null.
Okay, wenn du das unbedingt willst.
Aber wenn du es willst, dann kriegst du jetzt einen Timeout.
Aber schön erstmal die Punkte rausgehauen, exellent.
Aber du bist ja öfters dabei, sonst hättest du gar nicht so viele Punkte.
Das ist auf jeden Fall...
Gut, das ist jetzt nicht das Problem.
Das kriege ich gebacken, das habe ich ja schon mal gemacht.
Aber der Controller muss nicht in jeden Nanoleaf.
Die Nanoleafs werden untereinander verbunden, dann mit Kabels.
Sehe ich das richtig?
ESP-Tool-Exellent vorhanden, wer macht denn sowas auch mit Windows?
Interessant.
Das ist echt cool, das gefällt mir.
Da kann ich dann Facecam-Stream machen, weil ich einen coolen Hintergrund habe.
Weil das ist das allerwichtigste, man braucht einen coolen Hintergrund.
Hab gehört, der Apple M1-Chip ist stärker als der i9.
Es ist bestimmt ganz entscheidend von abhängig, was man ihm vor, was man ihm hinwirft.
Ein cooles ist schon irgendwo, ne?
Ja, das stimmt mit der Ecke.
Ich bestelle mir gleich was auf Amazon.
Eine Runde.
Aber mache ich Offstream.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich mir sowas hier bauen werde.
Sondern ich glaube eher, ich werde die LED-Strips beispielsweise mal verwenden, um am Bett neben Beleuchtung zu machen.
Netzteil bei AliExpress.
Netzteile und sowas, das ist das einzige, was ich nicht bei AliExpress bestelle.
Haben wir denn irgendwie einen 5 Volt?
Was haben wir hier unten?
5 Volt, 8 Ampere, okay, da kommt man ein bisschen weiter.
Bei 5 Volt, 8 Ampere ist ja auch nicht so viel, ne?
40. Warum wusste ich dafür, warum habe ich dafür jetzt einen Rechner gebraucht?
5 Volt, 12 Ampere.
Und damit kann man schon nochmal ordentlich LED-Strips betreiben.
Da haben halt die 12 Volt LED-Strips ihren Charme, wenn sie ein bisschen länger wird.
Aber man muss halt sagen, dass bei 12 Volt LED-Strips ist das Ansteu ein bisschen schwieriger.
Und man kann seinen Micro-Controller und seine Strips nicht so ohne Weiteres aus dem gleichen Netzteil betreiben.
Also kann man schon, da muss man halt ein bisschen was dazwischen machen, aber 5 Volt ist auf jeden Fall praktischer.
Egal, das probiere ich nachher mal aus.
Gut, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben.
Es gibt ja, so wie es aussieht, auch noch andere Projekte, nicht nur das, aber das ist eine coole Sache, ist nice.
Es ist eigentlich viel billiger bei AliExpress.
Also 1 Meter IP3060 kostet 5,86 und hier...
Moment, das ist 1 Meter, 5 Meter.
Okay. Ach nee, 18 dran.
Ja, 10 Euro Unterschied. Also man sieht schon, man spart wieder richtig was.
Ja, Cheat95, ich glaube, das Anschließen vom Controller ist das eine.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sich die 12 Volt LED-Strips dann überhaupt über die GPIO-Pinze ohne Weiteres ansteuern lassen.
3,3 Volt oder maximal 5 Volt Output.
Aber das sind nur dafür gedacht. Ich glaube, das macht es unnötig kompliziert.
Nein, die LIFAC-Sachen, die kann man über WLAN verwenden.
Ich verwende, ich steuere die nicht über die App.
Ich steuere die hier drüber. Ich hole mal kurz gucken, ob ich das zeigen kann, ob da gerade irgendwas sieht, was man nicht sehen soll.
Man sieht gerade...
Exzellent.
Hier drüber steuere ich mal die Lampen.
Wohnzimmer an aus, Wohnzimmer an aus. Ich steuere das alles über Home Assistant drüber.
Du packst nur die Data Pins an die LEDs.
Ja, ich weiß halt nicht, was die Data Pins für eine Spannung wollen.
Wenn's nur 5 sind, ist ja okay, dann geht's. Wenn die 12 wollen, geht's mit einem normalen ESP32-Schnitt.
Gute Frage. Wobei, das sind ja eh 5 Volt LED-Strips.
Das heißt eigentlich Lichtschalter sind bei dir immer angeschaltet. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, nee.
Also teils teils, ja.
Aber so lange bis ich da einen Relay installiert hab. Bei manchen hab ich ja einen Shelley drunter.
Und dann kann ich die Remote komplett an- und ausschalten.
Was die viel bessere Variante ist.
Ja.
Ich bestell mir mal ne Runde gleich, wenn ich hier mit dem Stream durch bin.
Dann gucken wir jetzt nochmal schnell weiter, was es hier noch bei Amazon, äh, bei denen heute im Angebot gegeben hat.
Okay, das sieht ja übelst räudig schlecht aus.
Dann gibt's hier so Zeug, was keiner braucht.
Alter, was der Scheiß für ein Geld kostet. So alles nicht gerechtfertigt.
Viel zu teuer, Alter, das ganze Zeug. TF.
Elektronik. Komfort-Beltwinder.
Ich, guck mal, ich geb doch nicht 116 Euro aus. Ich hab auch so ein Ding mal gekauft.
Hab sogar mal in einem Video gezeigt, sowas ähnliches. Ist ganz nett.
Aber viel zu teuer, um damit irgendwie 10 Rollhänden oder so. Nee, wie viel Rollhänden?
Keine Ahnung, 5-6 Rollhänden oder so auszustatten.
Hier ist nichts dabei.
Da ist jetzt nichts so Spannendes dabei gewesen.
Nope, fangen wir mal zu. Was haben die sonst noch für Smart Home?
Wir sind schon durch, Smart Home, easy. Gibt ja nicht wirklich viel.
So, dann gucken wir jetzt nochmal bei Do-It-Yourself.
Haben wir die hier auf?
Wo ist Smart Home? Smart and Do-It-Yourself tut man gut, weil es ein paar ordentliche Werkzeuge gibt.
Die komischen Kameras wollen uns aber echt in jeder Kategorie aufsperzen.
Ah, exzellent, Mundschutz. Den muss ich mir jetzt natürlich unbedingt noch bei Amazon kaufen.
Ich hab mir mal bei AliExpress ein 50er Pack bestellt.
Schon ein halbes Jahr her oder so. Hab ich sogar im Stream gemacht.
Mundschutz habe ich jetzt echt genug.
Die verwende ich ja auch gar nicht. Die habe ich einfach nur.
Das ist genauso wie das Klopapier, was ich damals online bestellt habe.
Da habe ich noch 78 Rollen übrig.
Ich habe ja so ein Packen Klopapier bei einem Online-Händler bestellt,
als gerade die Welt durchgedreht ist, was Klopapier angeht.
Da habe ich jetzt 78 Rollen übrig.
Crap.
Das ist eine Maske mit Loch. Sehe ich das richtig? Was bringt denn das?
Was ist das für Pepega Zeug?
Ach nee, das ist nur so eine Einlage. Ich dachte es wäre eine Maske mit Loch.
Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht, aber irgendwie ist bei diesen ganzen Deals zu 99,999% Mist dabei.
Ganz ganz selten mal irgendwas.
Prototyp Boards habe ich noch ein paar da, brauche ich nicht.
Wie soll denn das sein?
Was?
Das sieht ja dann absolut hoch weh. Will er sich ins Auge stechen oder was?
Das kann doch keiner erzählen, dass das irgendwas bringt.
Ja juckst du nicht mal kurz und hast die Schraube im Auge hängen. Was ein Blödsinn, Alter.
Oh Mann.
Also ich bin erst 2.36 Uhr on, nicht länger. Bin doch schon seit 13 Uhr an.
Ich glaube das dem mal.
Es gibt ja nur Müll.
Es gibt ja nur Müll bei Amazon gerade, echt nur Dreck, gar nichts Scheiß.
Ein Klodeckel von Myushii.
Irgendein Drecks billig China Multimeter. Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, sagt mir nämlich gar nichts. Ja höchstwahrscheinlich.
Ein Knopf, ein Knopf für 29, das muss aber ein sehr hoch.
Das ist geil, guckt euch mal das Bild an, du klickst drauf und das gibt es noch nicht mal.
Aufklebers für.
Boah das ist so übelstes Crap Werkzeug, Alter was ist das hier schon wieder?
Ist das hier so ein I fix it für Arme oder wie?
Wahrscheinlich.
Für 12 Euro, oh ja das wird bestimmt was Gutes sein.
12 Euro für ein gesamtes Set, das schreit schon äußerst hochwertig.
Funktioniert, aber es funktioniert wahrscheinlich genauso lang, bis du mal ein bisschen zu fest drehst und dann ist es ausgefranst.
Ist das ein Tennis? Ist das ein Tennisschläger?
Oder was ist das?
Eine Fliegenklatsche?
Mit einer Lampe?
Man kann es auch übertreiben, ich nehme da immer einen Schuh dafür, der rumliegt und dann BÄM.
Liprosli, BÄM, kriegt sie dann.
Mit Resort Visier und ACOG, mit ACOG, also ich bevorzuge meine Fliegenklatsche mit ACOG, ACOG Vierfach.
Was ist das?
Lanzenbeleuchtung.
Was ist das? Ah dein Enthülsen oder sowas? Brauche ich auch, alles am Start.
Irgendwie nur Kacke bei Amazon, gibt nichts.
Das ist Dremel für Arme?
Nee.
What the fuck? Achso, Farben, Spreisoren, ok.
Da ist wirklich nichts dabei, aber auch echt gar nichts.
Lohnt sich eigentlich gar nicht zu gucken.
Was ist das?
What?
MonkaS, haben die da alle Ersatzteile dran gemacht?
Ah, für den Wassersprengler, ok.
Ich gehe auch immer auf Amazon und kaufe mir einfach so einen Wassersprengler-Aufsatz.
Oh nee, ach du große Scheiße.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Hardcore Crap, Müllalarm, Alter.
Guck mal, für 21,59 wollen die uns...
Das sieht ja schon aus, als schmilzt ihr in der Hand.
Die wollen den Lötkolben verkaufen, inklusive ne Multimeter,
Zettel, Schraubentrier, Schrumpfschläuche, Zangskalpell.
Alter.
21 Euro.
Also, ich will ja keinem zu nahe treten, falls der das hat, aber...
Ich...
Ich würde es nicht einschalten, ehrlich gesagt. Ich hätte da meine Bedenken.
No one could possibly go wrong. Wahrscheinlich, nein, das ist wahrscheinlich alles absolut hochwertig hergestellt in China.
Nur mit den besten, der besten von den besten, ja.
Na, 4,5 Sterne, das sagt ja gar nichts aus.
Die Leute auf Amazon haben absolut keinen Plan.
Was macht der da?
Was macht der da? Auf Mainboard?
Übertaktet der gerade?
Oder was macht der da? Was macht der da?
Das sieht auf jeden Fall nach nicht allzu guten Ideen aus.
Und by the way, dieser Lötkolben, den man hier sieht, ist überhaupt nicht der Lötkolben, der hier abgebildet wird, oder? Ah, doch, fast.
Was ein Crap-Set, Alter.
Das Beste da draußen dürften wahrscheinlich noch die Ladung Schrumpfschläuche sein.
Ich mein, was ganz cool ist, dass so eine Saugedinge, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt, dabei ist,
das macht man rein, dann macht man das Lötzin weich und dann drückt man auf den Knopf und dann saugt das das Lötzin so ein zum Entfernen.
Entlötpumpe, ist das wirklich so?
Ja, das ist echt praktisch, da hab ich mir auch von der Weile mal eine gekauft.
Okay, also mag zwar verlockend sein für 21 Euro, weil man denkt, oh, man kriegt so richtig viel,
aber das meiste ist wahrscheinlich nach 1-2 mal benutzen dahin, gespeichert dann mal ordentlich dran drehen.
Diese Bits, die sehen schon so aus, als guck ich die einmal scharf an und hab die durchgedreht.
Und da noch dieser Lötkolben dabei, da, fuck, Alter.
Oh man, nee, das könnt ich mir nicht Reugengewissens geben.
Die Pinzette ist definitiv, da ist alles Müll, der Seitenschneider ist mit Sicherheit auch totaler Müll.
Pepe, please.
Die haben sie auch in die Hängematte gelegt und gesagt, lacht mal, ich muss ein Foto machen.
Wobei, die lagen nie in der Hängematte, die haben die da rein Photoshopped, oder?
Die Leute lagen nie in der Hängematte drin, die sind mal sowas von rein Photoshopped.
Die waren im Leben nicht in dieser Hängematte.
Guckt euch mal die Schulter an, guckt euch die Schulter von dem Dude an.
Und hier unten auch, exquisite Photoshop Skills.
Auch noch schlecht freigestellt.
Was sind das, Laubbläser oder Ob's?
Laubbläser oder sowas?
Vorks.
I Vorks, oder ist nur Vorks?
Kennt ihr Vorks?
Ich hab von Vorks noch nie was gehört, aber das heißt nichts.
Ich bin auch mit so großen Werkzeugen nicht so bewandt.
Der Chinese, der das Bild freigestellt, durfte nicht mehr als fünf...
Nee, das ging wahrscheinlich auch so, wir brauchen irgendeiner, der uns das Bild macht.
Ihr habt fünf Minuten Zeit und dann kam ein Chinese und hat gesagt, ich brauch nur 30 Sekunden.
Und hat es hochgeladen auf irgendeins, es gibt bestimmt irgendwelche Image-Freisteller-AI-Webseiten.
Und hat es da drüber gemacht.
Was ist das, ne Taschenlampe?
Ja, das ist eine Taschenlampe.
Für fünf Euro bei Fiverr bestellt, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Das, was ist denn das?
Robben?
Tacker, ist das ein Tacker?
Ach nee, das ist doch was, wo man C-Schrauben reinmacht und dann...
Ah, da nimmt man den Akkuschrauber und macht das vorne drauf und dann kann man quasi so nach und nach die Dinger da reinschrauben.
Das ist cool. Nicht, dass ich es brauchen würde, aber das ist nice.
Erstmal noch eine Barbecue Grill-Satt holen.
Also es ist schon unglaublich viel Crap dabei.
Das ist ja ein mega hässlicher Akkuschrauber.
Das sieht irgendwie nun ja...
Was Pippi Shell Toilet sieht? Ernsthaft, heißt das Ding so?
Pippi Shell Toilet Seat, exzellent Name.
Es ist so viel Crap bei Amazon dabei.
Könnten die sich nicht darauf beschränken?
Vielleicht ein paar wenige und dafür richtig gute Angebote, nicht so ein ganzes Müll?
Schweißgerät für fünf Euro ist ja fast noch besser als das Multimeter für acht.
Oder der Lötkolben und das Multimeter zusammen für zwanzig.
Man muss ja mal wirklich sagen, da ist auch sehr viel China Kram dabei.
Erstmal das Richtige, wenn man an den Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof muss.
So viel Schrott ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Kabelbinder, ja Kabelbinder könnte man tatsächlich mal wieder gebrauchen, aber nicht für zehn Euro.
Sind das die Premium Kabelbinder oder warum kosten die 16, 11 Euro?
Wobei das sind glaube ich recht viel, das sind 150.
Den habe ich nicht.
Das sah aus wie mal ein kleiner Agus-Schrauber.
Das ist aber auch G-Bait, die zeigen das hier, du machst das auf und dann kommt irgendwie sowas.
87 Euro fürs Fire HD 10, ja die Amazon Sachen lohnen sich eigentlich fast immer.
Aber wenn man es halt braucht, man muss es halt auf jeden Fall deploaten.
Weil so rein Amazon Stock ist, gehälst du ja nicht aus von Werbung.
Warum sollte man den Fire TV Stick flaschen wollen?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Fire TV Stick habe ich noch nie geflasht.
Die Amazon Tablets habe ich aber schon öfters mal etwas entamazonifiziert.
Cheat95 meint, 90% von dem Produkt der Liste würden aus dem Verkehr gezogen, wenn man die meldet.
Ja kann schon sein, also gerade bei dem ganzen China Zeug.
Es ist aber auch so viel unnützer Kram dabei, da ist ja schon so eine Brolle Klebeband eines der nützlichen Sachen.
Was haben sie denn hier zu bieten?
Ich meine, ich brauche sie, ich habe schon genug Bitsets und Gedöns.
Aber zu Abwechslung war es halbwegs gescheit, aber so viel Müll.
Das lohnt sich nicht weiter anzugucken, da ist ja echt nichts dabei.
Da ist ja echt nichts dabei.
Was sind denn die Top Deals heute?
Noch mehr Staubsäure Roboter brauche ich auch nicht.
Gibt es diese extra haltbaren Micro SDs, da könnte ich tatsächlich mal wieder welche von brauchen.
51 Euro?
Den gleichen Stick gibt es doch für 9 Euro oder so.
Warum ist denn der so teuer?
Ah, 512G.
Gut, braucht man nicht.
Ist auf USB Stick eigentlich ziemlich unsinnig.
Kann ich einfach eine externe SSD nehmen auf USB.
So mache ich es übrigens gerade aktuell bei den ganzen Sachen hier daheim.
Ich habe noch ein paar alte SSDs, einfach mit USB Adapter.
Besser als jeder USB Stick.
Nee Leute, das hat keinen Sinn.
Es gibt nichts.
Es gibt nur Müll.
Unter 20 Euro, ok.
Unter 20 Euro.
Monster Energy.
Oh ja, unbedingt.
Jacken, Unterhosen, Creme.
Playstation Now.
Soul Station.
Wischtücher.
Eins verlockender als das andere.
Oh, die Sims 4.
Ganz wichtig.
Ich brauche jetzt unbedingt die Sims 4 mit allen Endons.
Ah, ein Werkzeugkoffer für 5 Euro.
Das ist bestimmt auch richtig hochwertiges Zeug.
Generell dieses Banzmann Zeug ist auch absoluter Crap, Alter.
Der sieht schon teilweise so aus als Fels auseinander.
Nur Müll, Leute.
Nur Müll.
Krasser Gangster.
Das ist mal hier.
Die schreckt so gerade alle, während die das Foto für Amazon aufgenommen haben.
Amazon, das gucke ich mir nicht weiter an.
Das ist komplett sinnlos.
Alles klar.
Mehr Bobbes.
Okay, was haben Sie hier?
Auch beim China-Kram.
Die Schlelle mal drübergescrollt.
Braucht man alles nicht.
Super Mario Hausschuhe.
Ja, das ist ja noch das beste Angebot heute.
Puh, Sauna.
What the fuck.
Okay, es gibt nichts, was es nichts gibt mittlerweile.
Der soll tatsächlich ganz gut sein, wenn man große Sachen drucken muss, habe ich gelesen.
Warum genau hat hier der Staubsauger-Roboter einen Facebook-Logo obendrauf?
Ich weiß nicht, Facebook-Logos.
Ach so, das ist von denen hier für die Werbung.
Katzen ärgern für Faule.
Nee, das ist ja schon fast gefährlich.
Also je nach Laser ist es gefährlich für die Katze, wenn die sie in die Augen kriegen.
Deswegen ist das nichts, was ich random einfach in der Wohnung rumscheinen lassen würde.
Vor allem dieses fotogeschoppte Bild schon wieder.
Die größten Verhältnisse sind auch original.
Also die Katze und das Ding sind erst schon mal mindestens so groß wie das Sofa.
Alles klar.
Es gibt einen guten Tipp, wenn sich die Katze alleine fühlt.
Man kann mit seiner Katze einfach was machen, wenn man schon eine Katze hat.
Der Tisch.
Was ist das?
Der Tisch hier ist geil.
Also Katze ist zu fett, kann ich ja noch nachvollziehen.
Aber man kann mit seiner Katze einfach was machen, wenn es der langweilig ist.
Dafür hat man doch eine Katze.
Man hat doch nicht einfach nur eine Katze am Start, um eine Katze zu haben.
Ein bisschen was machen mit der kann man doch schon.
Resin-Drucker.
Bestimmt auch wieder sowas, was super genau ist.
Der soll auch ganz gut sein, wenn man große Sachen drucken will.
Hier ist aber auch wieder so viel Müll dabei.
Ich will ja teilweise mein Geld wirklich ausgeben, aber es gibt einfach nichts.
Ja, Cheat-Film 95 gibt es bestimmt viel zu viele davon.
China-Chat.
Ah ja, ja, Gaming-Handheld.
Das ist ein Scheißgift, Alter.
Fahrrad, fährst du einfach mit dem Fahrrad über die Pizza und schneidest.
Irgendwie ist die Idee sogar noch ganz cool, ja.
Motorrad-Pizza-Schneider, Fahrrad-Pizza-Schneider.
Das ist nur ein Party-Gag, das geht aus höchsten der Gefühle.
Was ein Müll.
Also, die machen auch Rucksäcke mittlerweile.
Die machen alles, das ist ein Riesen-Laden.
Okay, Leute.
Ein Toy-Story, oder was auch immer.
Schuh-Excellent.
Also, manchmal denke ich mir, ich würde ja gerne Geld ausgeben, aber es gibt einfach nichts.
Was habe ich denn eigentlich alles noch?
Im Shopping-Basket drin.
Habe ich schon längst bestellt?
Habe ich auch schon bestellt?
Okay, jetzt weg.
Empty.
Na ja.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Immerhin Schluss für heute.
Also, Schluss wenn man morgen früh ist mit der Aufwach-Stream.
Um 10 oder so.
Was hast du mit Amazon gemacht?
Ich habe ein Bild auferleht.
Das gehört nicht zu Amazon.
10, 10.30.
Das letzte Mal haben wir auch immer in dem Dreh angefangen.
Ich gehe mir jetzt erst noch mal die LED-Strips bestellen.
Offstream.
Und dann sehen wir uns, Leute.
Das war heute heute ein spontaner Mittag-Stream.
Dein Basket schaut anders aus.
Vielleicht, weil du eingeloggt bist.
Ich bin ja nicht eingeloggt.
Oder vielleicht, weil ich meinen Browser auf Englisch stehen habe.
Keine Ahnung.
Ist der Friseur am Streamson?
Nicht, nicht.
Oh.
Ist schon fertig, Streamson.
Alles klar, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Wir sehen uns morgen früh.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.